e
I'd like to call the executive session
to order representative Drago can you
to the flag of the United States of
America and to the Republic for which it
stands one nation under God indivisible
with liberty and justice for
please representative avalani pres uh
representative Kastle ring pres
representative plan
again representative
L representative Warden representative
Drago here representative mannon here
representative
Farmington fton sorry said your name
representative Hall here representative
L here representative Sullivan here
representative kahill here
representative d sylvestro
representative Susi here representative
buard here representative McKenzie
present representative Newell here
representative lir here representative
you're still out represent stop
represent kill could you check yours
they're in series hey Mr Allen could you
please
you this one's working
here I don't see there we
go we're back oh you guys are miracle
workers but you guys are still down over
there all
up okay okay I see the light there you
go just got you're all over it okay last
here okay good morning everyone looking
forward to another exciting day in the
labor in the labor committee and uh
we'll start by executing a c a couple of
okay I'd like to open the session the
executive session on HB 282 increasing
the maximum benefits for First
Responders critically injured in the
line of duty uh representative Warden do
you have a motion I move inexpedient to
legislate on 282 FM a motion inexpedient
to legislate is made by representative
Warden is there a second represent
Flanigan as you're discussing other
matters do you have a second on this
thank you I appreciate
that H Mr Warden would you like to yeah
like to address your your motion please
just briefly this bill was designed to
double the total benefits paid from the
current
$500,000 to a million dollars per banum
we heard some testimony that the current
maximum 500,000 has not yet been reached
in any bium so I think we're better off
just leaving it as it is usually when
you expand a pot things find a way of
filling it and I think we should be more
conservative on this thank
you and representative flang do you have
anything to add to the
motion sorry Mr chairman no I agree with
uh representative Warden I I I
too feel that if there was a need or
demand then we should be looking at it
but since it hasn't met that Threshold
at all anyway that we should just leave
it the way it is okay are there any
other comments or discussions
representative solivan
during the hearing I
um asked a question about the um the
possibility of a uh New Hampshire
version of 911 I'm sure that we don't
have any skyscrapers or anything but it
is not inconceivable that we could have
a true disaster um where we would have
multiple fire firefighters who might be
um injured or killed and if that were to
happen um 500,000 wouldn't be enough and
frankly a million dollars wouldn't be
enough um and one of the um people
testifying uh suggested that perhaps
there should be no no cap on this
because if you had a disaster like that
we would want to spend the money um so
um I'm going to oppose the itl because I
think um going to a million would be a
good start thank
representative McKenzie thank
you I I want to uh agree with
representative Sullivan on this issue
you know the nature of the business is
incredibly
unpredictable so in instead of building
the fund to absorb potential uh issues
and potential crisis that that uh that
might occur in using this opportunity to
do that instead we decide we're going to
we're going to cut that back because
well there's no
need well the as you mentioned
9911 at 8:00 in the morning there was no
need at 7:30 but at 8:00 or 8:30 when
that thing hit the the towers it was
there was a big need that's the nature
of the business and so we should take
this opportunity to build that fund up
to absorb things that could potentially
occur now I can tell you man
Chester by the grace of God there were
two firefighters in the last couple
years one of which we pulled out of a
building dead he was dead in the
building and they revived him on the
outside went back to work the other one
was hanging out the window burnt half
his hands burnt them all uh he suffered
very serious injuries and ended up in
the Boston Hospital those are two
firefighters in one town over the last
couple years it almost died all almost
died one of them did but for the grace
of God we revived him so this is the
nature of the business take this
opportunity to build a fund don't cheap
out on this thing you you owe it to the
firefighters and officers who who do
this kind of work so thank you Mr
chairman thank you I appreciate your
comments president K thank you Mr chair
uh I was here when we created this uh
fund and it was in response to to the
shooting of a young uh Manchester police
officer several wounds in his abdomen uh
doing
permanent irreparable harm to his organs
and bipartisan we could we couldn't pass
it fast
enough and I I note that in this bill
there is no effort to increase the
125 per person maximum is just adding
more in the in the event that there are
multiple people injured
and you know with the things that happen
in the world today you could have
firefighters police officers
EMTs they're all out there we don't know
what they're going to run into there
could be any number of injuries any
number of people hurt you know with
those kind of injuries and we shouldn't
be waiting to see if it happens we
should raise this to to to uh 100,000
and hoping we never we never reach that
thank you all right sir thank you
what is that Susy thank you Mr chairman
I want to Echo the sentiments of my
colleagues here because someone who
worked in Nashville for 29 years um came
very close to being paralyzed for the
rest of my life when an air conditioner
from three stories above came down
knocked me in the head knocked me
unconscious woke up about four minutes
later gagging on blood spitting out
teeth hole in my tongue forehead wide
open
so when I went to work that morning it
was never expected that was going to
happen but it did so I just want to Echo
the sentiments of these people in here
that you know we shouldn't wait till
something happens to expand the fund if
we don't use it that's great I think
that's the best way to go let's not use
it um but if it's if something drastic
happens in the state I definitely think
the money should be there so thank
you okay representative Clint excuse me
thank you Mr Speaker um we're always
talking about thanking our First
Responders and backing our First
Responders so let's uh let's show them
that we really do and uh pass this Bill
thank
you thank
you represent flan thank you Mr chairman
um I I hear all the comments and I can
appreciate our Our First Responders um
at the same token is if we do go over
that amount I would imagine we could
probably find money in the general fund
to to supplement it if in fact it went
over because there always the rainy day
fund that we tend to have millions of
dollars in uh and I think the math is
showing that as representative Warden uh
said that um that we haven't gone over
the number so I think we should just
leave it there thank
you represent kale thank you Mr CH I I
wonder if the the timing of the Calamity
would make a difference if we were not
in session what with if the uh governor
and executive Counsel had just met that
Wednesday and now we have to wait two
weeks for another meeting uh how long
would it take to arrange this fund to
suddenly
appear okay I I do have I have one
comment
so just bear with me a sec I I was
intimately aware of 911 I watched the
Pentagon burn as my wife was in it and
so I understand the impact of of those
types of things and I and I am of the
opinion and we thought about this before
we made the motion is that we could
react if necessary and I look at the the
current state of the of the fund and we
have not gone above two-thirds of that
fund
historically and so I think it's enough
to to take those challenges that
come uh that we would anticipate if
there's a challenge that we don't
anticipate that I do have faith that we
as legislators and with the executive
branch could handle that and and that's
why I support an
comments seeing uh no comments Mr clerk
rooll representative avalani
yes clerk
yes uh representative
Flanigan representative Le and use your
mics please uh as this is being
recorded representative Warden yes
representative Drago yes representative
mannon yes representative Fairington yes
representative Hall
yes representative
L yes Representative solvan no
Representative kahill no representative
d sylvestro no representative Susi no
Representative bushard no representative
McKenzie no representative Noel
no okay Representative lir no
representative stab
no representative
kraton
yes and represent Warden uh will you be
doing the uh committee report sure all
right and represent s who would you like
to do The Minority
Report Roger and if we get have the
reports in uh in the next 24 hours that'
be great so by noon tomorrow an extended
hours was the count on that
1195 and this closes the executive
session on HB 282 I'd now like to open
the executive session on HB
586 establishing an employee assistance
program for smalltown First Responders
and making appropriation
therefore representa kering do you have
a motion yes yes uh I motion to itl um
when we heard the testimony you just
make the motion then we then we discuss
you're all over it you're leaning
forward you're good represent Hall do
you have a second yes I
second all right now representative C
would you like to speak to your motion
yes so when we heard testimony we heard
a lot about how uh workers compensation
uh can cover a lot of these Services
also when you look into uh a lot of the
stuff that came in through the portal
and different comments uh there are some
other services uh that are not
government related uh one of them is New
Hampshire 988 um there's also some other
services out there that do this exact
thing in the private sector that also
helped through workers comp when we
up okay thank you representative Hall
would you like to speak to your
motion nothing really Dad I think
there's sufficient services that we
don't need to add this on okay thank you
and representative suan for a
comment yes um and we actually discussed
this the um during the hearing um it
appeared that some of the folks
testifying were looking at a fiscal note
um however the committee did not have
that fiscal note the committee still
does not have that fiscal note and I
think that fiscal note um would be very
helpful in figuring out if there's a way
to um make this work and I would um hope
that we could postpone um voting on this
until we have all the information that
this okay uh good
this represent Flanigan thank you Mr
chairman and in due respect
representative Sullivan um the motion is
based that there's other services that
are out there it's not the fiscal note
the money the dollar amount that it
would cost and I respect representative
Sullivan's opinion however you know I
think where we're looking at is the fact
that the service is already out there
not the dollar amount of the
services okay got good point any other F
further
comments representative
Sullivan yeah I'll Dove a little deeper
then um the uh employee assistance
program that uh was proposed here is a
fast acting process um workers comp is
not um and um when someone has this type
of uh
um trauma um they need quick assistance
and that that quick assistance might be
enough to make it so that workers comp
doesn't come into play um and will save
money o o overall a lot of times these
folks just need one or two um sessions
with a counselor to um deal with the
PTSD that's that's building and I think
the uh employee assistance program is
the ideal mechanism to do that and I
don't think we were looking at a great
deal of cost but unfortunately we didn't
have an accurate cost um so um
I I intended to put put forth an
amendment um uh to um to put that cost
into the bill but uh just don't have the
information yet so I would renew my
request to uh postpone so that we could
um provide another fast acting tool for
these um um First Responders to um deal
and Mr Allen any word on a fiscal note
and we talked about it
you are there any other comments
representative kill thank you Mr chair
uh it would seem that if the EAS system
is the ideal uh assistance and the the
bill would increase the funding to allow
them to meet the need and I I don't
doubt there is a need then I would ask
the committee to defeat the itl so that
we might postpone and get more
information and and see really what the
what the dollar amount is and if we if
whether or not we're willing to make
that I think small investment to prevent
other additional costs uh such as
workers comp and perhaps uh very serious
uh mental health issues in our first
are there any other further comments
representative McKenzie just a a point
of clarification Mr chairman um workers
comp has been mentioned here uh I I
don't think workers comp covers uh
Employee Assistance programs now they
may what they probably would cover most
likely is if somebody fell apart and had
a mental breakdown or some other related
issues over um you know but they don't
cover that I know of uh those kinds of
programs so just for
clarification thank you any other
comments representative
labry regarding the the financial note
on this I know we haven't seen one or
heard one specifically but was there
testimony from the sponsor correct me if
I'm wrong was it $150,000 ask in 106 for
somebody to administrate this is is that
what the cost was
that's just a question I the reason I
asked the question with a hiring freeze
and budget cuts I'm just trying to
square it all that's
all
standby representative
Solin I believe that as we were doing
sort of about back of the envelope um
math um I believe the amount that was
mentioned was
$270,000 um I I would I would be uncom
comtable um creating an amendment using
a number that was just sort of thrown
out during um a hearing um especially
knowing that it's it's a second
committee bill it needs a fiscal note
it's got to show up sometime so um I I
just think we a better informed uh U
conclusion there's Schultz or cor stab
sorry thank you um I I just have a
question we're talking about workman's
comp and from what I understand this was
um to uh help very small rural um
firefighting groups and also um
volunteer firefighting groups do
represent
suiv with regard to workers comp um it
would cover PTSD but you would have to
prove that the PTSD was related to your
firefighting work which can be a
laborous um uh project so um the
employee assistance program doesn't
require proof of a you know connection
um workers comp does that's that's why
this employee um assistance program is
um uh I I think a good stop Gap in in
between um someone who's you know
feeling the build of um trauma and
Trauma related mental health and someone
who is completely broken down to the
point where they need workers comp to
cover you know missed work medical bills
and so on um it's it's an in between
layer that that can avoid workers comp
thank
you okay so th this is a great
discussion and I'm just R reviewing my
notes and listening to the the
recommendations
I I guess where I fall on it is that
uh I think there are other ways there
there definitely is a way for these
people to get the compensation they
needed there are other agencies
available and that those agencies aren't
necessarily tied to the fiscal note uh
so subject to any further questions I'd
like to go ahead and hold the vote
and clerk if you can call the
role representative avalani
yes clerk yes representative
Flanigan yes representative lean
yes representative Warden yes
representative Drago yes representative
mannon yes representative Fairington yes
representative Hall yes representative l
yes representative Sullivan no
Representative kahill no representative
D sylvestro no representative Susi no
Representative buard no
representative McKenzie sorry did I say
that
already representative Noel newel
no Representative lir no representative
okay 119 excuse me Mr chair I wasn't
called oh I didn't call you yeah you
mentioned it but you oh representative
McKenzie I apologize no no okay well I
did it right at
least okay and and the vote is 119
y all right and representative kessle
ring uh will you do the committee report
for the committee yes and
representative Sullivan for a Minority
that and this closes session on HB
586 i' now would like to open the
session on HB 299
this is relative to the award of
attorney fees and costs in workers
compensation claims and representative
labry do you have a motion to make I do
I motion to itl House Bill
299 and representative avalani do you
have a a motion to make I will second
the motion Mr chairman and M uh Mr labry
will you uh do you have comments or uh
statement to make on your motion brief
comments this build generally advocates
for attorneys to be able to capture
unlimited fees and costs Upon A Le level
one hearing at the Department of Labor
currently attorneys are able to collect
those fees at the level two appeal
hearings the committee also felt that it
would uh Drive insurance rates and it
would also potentially drive more
claims okay thank you and representative
avalani do you have uh comments to your
motion uh representative La uh was very
eloquent thank you thank you all right
are there any other comments
representative McKenzie sir thank you uh
I I would just take exception Mr chair
to the uh comment about
unlimited unrestrained uh costs uh in
the sense that uh the cost for for this
program this benefit or whatever uh is
would be the same I would think as it is
for the other levels and it would be uh
governed by the uh the department of
label who has to approve all these uh
fees so it's not it's not
unrestrained okay fair enough thank you
right was
Solin
um I would agree with that point and I
would also raise another point that um
uh there was testimony heard that when
these um hearings are scheduled if
there's representation for both sides
they schedule them for an hour if
there's no represent presentation on um
the worker side they schedule it for an
hour and a half um so effectively um the
message sent is that when there's
somebody in the room that knows what
they're doing um and guiding the the
hearing in a productive and uh
reasonable way um it's it's much more
efficient um the other advantage of
having an attorney involved is that if
an if a worker goes to an attorney um
with with a just a bad appeal um you
know the insurance company has denied
the claim and the um the worker mad and
goes to the attorney saying I want you
to help me fight this thing if they've
got no prayer the attorney is not going
to represent them and they will explain
why they have a bad case um so again I
think you get more efficiency out of
people who are represented by a
competent workers to um attorney so um
uh I think this would actually be an
improvement on the system thank you okay
thank you are there any representative K
thank you Mr chair I I I also think that
the presence of an attorney uh as my
colleague said you know would help
screen out uh cases that really weren't
going to go anywhere but also I think it
would likely bring a a settlement that
both parties can live with and that's
equitable
uh you've probably seen the ads on TV
you know you got an injury you know the
our attorneys you know get you what you
deserve and you know the other the
insurance company will crumble just when
they see our name on the on the case
that might be a little bit of
exaggeration but I think even attorney
Russo felt that uh you know there was a
question about you know attorneys cost
more or they just bring more value so uh
I'm going to buote against the
itl thank you
sir representative Flanigan
thank you Mr chair and I don't want to
um pound this into the ground but I mean
these people are represented by
attorneys it's not a matter of if they
can get an attorney they they can get
attorneys the issue is who pays for it
and about 10 five years ago six years
ago uh chairman infantine and I worked
on revising the entire workers comp
statue in the state of New Hampshire it
was a lot of work uh but the concern was
that workers comps uh premiums were
going really too high to a point where
we only had three
carriers now we have a much larger
number than three carriers in the state
of New Hampshire but that's all I going
say as there is attorneys there that
that will represent them so okay and
represent K thank you Mr chair and just
to assist my learning colleague with
whom I've served several terms uh we did
hear from uh the uh attorney represented
the insurers uh that
in in fact uh our our rates are down
because our safety standards our safety
practices are better I think that's the
key to this and if we improve safety as
in the public sector as well just
another plug for that um then then we
could do better it's the safety keeping
if reduce the claims then you have fewer
people going on appeals you have fewer
injuries that's that's the key to lower
all right seeing no further
comments Mr clerk can you call the
role representative avalani
yes clerk yes representative Flanigan
yes representative lean yes
representative Warden yes representative
drgo yes representative mannon yes
representative Fairington yes
representative Hall yes representative L
yes representative Sullivan no
Representative kahill no representative
D sylvestro no representative Susi no
Representative bushard no
representative McKenzie
no representative Newell no
Representative lir no representative
stab no representative kraton
yes
119 okay okay the vote is 119 and uh
representative labry for the committee
report yes sir thank you and for the
Minority
you and this closes the executive
session on HB
299 I'd now like to open the executive
session on HB 303
relative to requiring the Department of
Labor review and adopt workers
occupational safety requirements that
are similar to oia standards
motion I I move that we retain this bill
and do I have a second thank you second
Mr
chairman thank you rosone avalani are
there any uh discussion to this motion
represent Sullivan yes um
as I testified um last week um this bill
has come a long way it has vastly
improved from where where it was four
five years ago um that doesn't mean it's
perfect um and I'm uh persuaded that uh
if we retain the bill and continue to
work in a bipartisan way to try to um
I'm not going to say perfect it it might
never be perfect but improve um make
make it a bit better so it's more
palatable to the entire committee or at
least the majority of the committee then
um I'm I'm not going to say I'm happy to
do that but I'm willing to do that and
um uh been working on this too long to
uh uh to see it go down in flame so I'm
happy to keep working on it so thank you
and I I just uh from my perspective you
know if you look at the numbers that
were provided us um over the weekend the
the fact of matters our public employees
are injured at a higher rate 2 to 4%
based on the year than there than the um
than the private sector and the uh I'm
not saying it's a direct cause to OSHA
but clearly anything we could do to
protect our workers we should
do um but I look at this bill as it is
and there's two big concerns that jump
out of me first is that I mean if you if
you take the OSHA regulations and you
put them into this room you print them
all out they would fill this room and my
fear is that we subject New Hampshire to
that volume and the and the cost
associated with implementing that and I
understand that the bill is written so
that that's not supposed to happen but
I'm not convinced it wouldn't happen and
then the other thing is that the
department uh has said that they would
need seven additional workers plus
additional space to put these people in
and I I just I'm not comfortable with
that under the current budget um
circumstances so Rec recognizing the
importance of the bill and the work
that's already been done I would like to
commit the committee to uh look at it
more detail and maybe uh come with
something that we can all agree to um in
the near future represent labry I would
just dovetail with what you said
regarding uh The Hires in the new
building as written this is a
multi-million dollar bill with the
request here uh is the first issue with
the hiring frees and budget cuts again
uh the second thing is my thought would
be if there is a union option for
additional safety as we we hear all the
unions say that the safety is
unparalleled within the unions I would
request that maybe that's view looked at
too within this the research that we can
if we do decide to continue with this
but it's awfully expensive and it's
definitely going to continue to be a big
project I think thank you any other
comments representive Flanigan thank you
Mr chairman um I also support the motion
to retain however I think what we need
to probably do is look at a phased in
approach in that maybe establish a
fund that
says taking B taking by getting a
quarter of a loaf instead of the whole
loaf if I can use that that term meaning
that some areas may be need uh changes
immediately some not needing the
implementation of the OSHA so it might
be on on a coordinated basis where we
say to labor is that we need to look at
this but we've got x amount of dollars
to spend and go from there that's all I
was
thinking good point represent Dro thank
you Mr
chairman the study that uh was sent over
this or the numbers that were sent over
this weekend I was actually surprised
that public sector was um 2 to 4% higher
for um injuries my concern concern is
actually the Department of Labor put it
in the email that that could just be
because public sector is much better at
reporting injuries and I as a private
sector employer I know plenty of
employees who just offer to pay for
their employee to go to urgent care and
get stitches that doesn't get reported
and there's a lot of times private
sector employees don't even report the
entry they got if it's not serious
enough that doesn't happen in the public
sector they they're very good at
reporting everything and I think that's
where the numbers get skewed so without
good data I don't see and I'm not sure
we'll ever get that data but I don't see
how we can force municipalities to spend
Millions upgrading their standards and
we did hear partial testimony on that
that depends on the M municipality and
what they have for safety gear now but
the expenses might be extraordinary and
we all campaigned we all heard our taxes
are crazy so I'm not sure how we can
stick our constituents with that type of
expense fair enough good
all right um Mr clerk do you want to
call a rooll
please representative
avalani
yes clerk yes representative Flanigan
yes representative lean yes
representative Warden yes representative
drgo yes representative mannon yes
representative Fairington yes
representative Hall
yes representative L Bri yes
representative Sullivan yes
representative kahill yes representative
D
sylvestro no
[Laughter]
yes representative Susi yes
representative buard yes representative
McKenzie yes representative Newell yes
representative lir yes representative St
yes and representative Katon yes it's
unanimous all right so uh by a vote of
20 to nothing we've uh agreed to retain
this bill and I look forward to seeing
what we can come up with uh over the
next year thank you this closes the
hb303 I'd now like to open the session
735 on HB
735 uh through discussions with the
sponsor uh we believe that there is an
amendment that could come to place that
would be an improvement over this bill
and I'd like to postpone the executive
session until next week so I close the
executive session on HB
735 point of order Mr chairman sir um
was the was the moving of our meeting
I'm sorry we normally be in room 307
correct it's posted at 210 211 it is
posted up there in the calendar and it's
on the calendar okay I'm just saying all
the emails that we got I was like
where's
7:35 so okay thank you very much yep
thank you yeah no it's posted in uh it's
in a calendar thank you good
point okay I'd like to open a session on
it's a bill relative to the employment
of military spouses in the event of
involuntary
deployment of a service
member and representative L do you have
a motion yes so I motion to otpa with
the uhu with an amendment here if I
could okay
um uh yes please okay so this is a uh an
amendment that was a stand by stand by
do we have a second I'll second
represent Hall thank you so much and now
for your Amendment okay so this is a
amendment that we had worked on as a b
bipartisan committee uh representative
Hall and Schultz weighed in on this
there were five changes that we made um
I don't know if you guys have a copy of
this did we have a copy for everybody
I'll just read it if I if You' like this
just a copy of the amendment um so
basically what we did was we added this
to try to close it off a little bit and
made it one year in one day so regarding
the amount of time that a spouse could
be not at the place of uh where they'
work it was it was up to one year and
one day so it wasn't
open-ended uh the second item here was
we defined what court meant uh local
court or
magistrate and the third item we had
here was employer shall provide
employees with written acknowledgement
deployment the fourth item we had is
that the employer this was just a typo I
think the employer may choose not to
re-employ the employee if the employer
establishes that circumstances have so
changed this would be in the case of if
the uh if the business was sold or
whatnot and then five uh if a violation
is found the employer shall be liable
for reinstatement and back pay uh of any
benefits lost due to a violation Mr
chairman sir point of order I think I
think it is
um I I believe it's required that we
have a written copy of an amendment
before we vote on it so um okay I I
agree with that um Davis can you go get
just burn 20 copies of this and we'll
minutes what I'm say
again yeah okay yeah 25 for the audience
as well it's got notes on it but feel
free to take it so we'll reset for five
minutes please hang tight and uh we'll
get that out to you yes sir more of a
point of order uh I think the motion was
OTP with with an amendment what we
really need to do is introduce the
amendment vote vote on the am and then
we V vote OTP with an amend that's what
we're doing okay I'm just saying the
original the original motion was OTP uh
and then we're making a motion on the
amendment we'll vote on the amendment
and then we'll go back to the OTP cool
thank
you
e
all right representative lbr if you
could just hand those out we'll give
folks a minute to look at
uh we'll go ahead and see if there's any
questions
um just the actual
Amendment yeah he just underlined I'm
sorry
I'd like to call back in session uh
discussion for the executive uh session
on HB
225 representative La has handed out
Amendment
hotel and representative labry could you
go through your changes as everyone has
a chance to look at what the committee's
done and I just wanted to
thank the subcommittee uh for the work
that they did on listening to testimony
and making uh adjustments as as
appropriate so over to you sir sure uh
okay so the the First Amendment here and
everything's underlined and numbered um
basically the the um original Bill kind
of left this openend open-ended so we
just tucked in to to close it off so it
wasn't like forever one year and a day
so that was the first First Amendment
here the second one is uh we need to
identify what the word Court meant and
uh Court of course means a local court
or
one this was just an acknowledgement
that employers would provide employees
with written acknowledgement of notice
of their
deployment um so that there wouldn't be
any
confusion number four second page
I believe the word not was left out here
and the employer may choose not to
re-employ the employee if the employee
establishes some circumstances have
changed change meaning you know possibly
the business was sold or
whatnot and then number five of course
was if there was a violation found the
employer would be liable for
reinstatement back pay and any benefits
lost to the violation so we feel that
these five changes tightened up the
bill okay are there any questions to the
Amendment representative McKenzie uh
under Section uh five I guess it's 5B so
if a violation is
found um does the U the claimant recover
legal
costs to have to enforce to have to
enforce the law so is it their burden to
uh to fund this whole appeal so
representative McKenzie if you look
under line nine it says the Department
of Labor or local Court may also award
the employee reasonable attorney
fees so that's in the that's in that
section thank
you ready thank
you representative Flanigan thank you Mr
chairman um uh item number
three employer shall provide the
employees with written acknowledgement
of the notice of deployment explicitly
confirming adherence of this term is
that like a a wall posting that the
employer has to say that if you are
deployed or involved with a deployment
that we
will adhere to this
law Mr chair please I don't know that's
a specific wall posting but it's
definitely a written acknowledgement to
that to the employees to the employees
okay okay that's fine that's basically
closing the loop to make sure that
communication has occurred between the
employee notification and the employers
coming back saying yeah I got this
you're covered the the only reason the
only concern I had was that it was
almost like saying saying well the
employer is going to tell the person
that they're being deployed and I'm like
no it's EAS the other way around if you
read it the first way that's right but
the question in if when we heard
testimony
was just confirming that both parties
knew what was going on it's a notice yep
y represent
Salan on your first um change um it says
U involuntary mob mobilized for up to
one year in one day um so if it goes one
year and 2
days the U Reemployment is not
necessarily at some point Mr chair if I
might please at some point
representative we had to draw the line
in the sand someplace for this and close
the loop so at one year in one day that
closes the loop at one year in two days
it's no longer
effective and I guess I would follow up
please I I would just question whether
or not um it is
extremely uncommon for a deployment to
go more than a year and a day
absolutely 10 years ago a year
deployment was sort of the standard and
it's a year to the day they I mean
you're you're track very closely uh
currently deployments are six to nine
months um and so I I think a year and a
day is is completely reasonable based on
deployment um
schedules every more
in lines 26 and
27 we just talked about a second ago
says that the employers should provide
shall provide written acknowledgement of
deployment that's fine that could be an
email for example but then it says
explicitly confirming adherence to the
terms of this
section that
isn't it's sort of nonsensical I don't
know what that means does that email
have to say that yes we've received
acknowledgement of your deployment and
we as an employer adhere to
RSA 110 colon C1 colon A-1 or whatever
it is yeah I mean it's is it I mean
those are two different things it could
say they can written written
acknowledgement acknowledge acknowledge
acknowledge re um that they know about
the deployment and they shall confirm
adherance to the I just don't think I
don't think it's clearly written like
guess the point represent
labr it could be dumbed down okay and no
disrespect basically what it means is
when you draft the letter and there is a
correspondence there needs to be
reference made to what we're talking
about so it's just not off the cuff and
just a a general statement that I'm
leaving and I'll be back in a year it
needs to be it needs to reference some
of which is what been talked about out
here in this section five okay if that
makes sense it maybe it is UN unclear
but we we suppose we could clean it up
but I think it's clear to most okay
represent K thank you Mr chair I mean to
that point I mean I I think it's pretty
straightforward if you say yes I will
hold your
job you doesn't you don't have to quote
the RSA to make it to make it work and
okay I like it all right good any other
questions representative McKenzie uh the
only question I have is on the uh uh the
section of the law that you put this in
I haven't had a chance to look that up
but the Department of Labor has um has a
whole section on protections and things
like that um but this doesn't I I don't
know that they have that they're in that
110 C area so I I'm just I just wonder
if this is should be moved over uh under
the uh Department of Labor uh section of
the
law I would say it'd be a great question
if I could sir to the Department of
Labor to ask them that's out of my pay
scale of my pay scale yeah if I may
address his concern when I originally
saw this bill I looked up the rsas and
chapter
110- C col one is about employment
protection for members of National Guard
State militia uh when they're when
they're called on duty and this adds
that was C colon one this new section is
C colon 1-A it's more specific so it it
does follow nicely with the existing RSA
opinion would it be possible to listen
to the uh get some opinion from the
do miss Albert do you have uh can you
give us some Enlightenment
good morning uh John garrian general
counsel with the Department of Labor
with me is Deputy Commissioner Danielle
Albert um representative wardens is
correct that that uh the existing 110c
covers employment protections for
members of the National Guard and state
militia um the Department of Labor's
Authority regarding that section of law
is located in 11e which uh is true it's
not our typical uh neighborhood of laws
um but that does that is where that
exists now this would amend that portion
of the law okay and alalani thank you Mr
chairman uh for further clarification
under section four line three um it does
reference a um Federal section um I I
know that you know we're subject to uh
state laws um would that be something if
this does go forward that the department
could clean up in the Senate to Define
that make the definition a state
definition we would certainly support
such a technical clarification on that
um we had email correspondence to that
effect um there are I mean from a
technical point of view there are there
are different ways to do that um as the
department uh provided to represent
representative avalani um the state law
can reference a federal standard we
would ly do our best to ascribe to the
federal standard um it makes it kind of
difficult to read um and then also
there's no you know when the federal
standard changes that changes the
standards even though there's no input
from the New Hampshire legislature um on
that so um we would I think be
supportive of anything that makes the
law clear kind of whichever way the law
goes um so but whether or not the Senate
can take that up is not a thing we'll
overall take a position on that we're
happy to provide technical guidance on
Words that could be put
there thank you thank you Mr
chairman okay uh seeing no further
questions we're going to vote on the
amendment as presented by representative
labry and if you could call the
role representative
avalani
yes clerk yes representative
Flanigan yes representative lean yes
representative Warden yes representative
drgo yes representative mannon yes
representative fingon yes representative
Hall yes representative L yes
representative Sullivan yes
representative kahill yes representative
D sylvestro yes representative Susi yes
representative bushard yes
representative McKenzie yes
representative Newell yes representative
lir yes representative stop Yes
representative Katon yes it's
unanimous okay so now back to the motion
um at hand representative avalani do you
have a motion to make thank you Mr
chairman I now move otpa for House Bill
225 and representative Sullivan do you
have a second yes and representative
avalani would you like to speak to your
motion point of information y should his
motion refer specifically to amendment
number
75h that's the amendment that's the
ogpa 075
H but that wasn't ex expressed in the
motion so expressed that's the only
amendment we're looking at I realize
that okay so so expressed fair enough
thank you okay represent avalani would
you like to speak to your motion uh
thank you Mr chairman I think that we
have uh talked about this at length and
uh it's time to move it forward thank
you okay representa suvan would you like
to speak to your motion a little um
please the um I I'm not a military guy
um but I do respect and uh appreciate
the service that uh our military does in
these deployments and uh I'm also a uh a
labor guy and so I value um uh job
protection so this does both and for
that reason I support
it thank you I appreciate the comments
any other further
questions saying none Mr Clark can you
call the rule on
otpa or
h225 with Amendment
H representative avalani
yes clerk yes representative Flanigan
representative Warden oh sorry I skipped
represent leam yes representative Warden
no uh representative drgo yes
representative mannon yes representative
farington yes representative Hall yes
representative L yes representative
Sullivan yes representative kahill yes
representative Z sylvestro yes
representative Susi yes
representative bushard yes
representative McKenzie yes
representative Newell yes representative
lir yes representative stop Yes
representative
kraton
yes 191 19 to1 is the vote is there any
objection to putting this bill on
consent seeing no objection
representative Ward thank you uh we'll
put it on consent and I will write the
the committee report
are there any further questions good
close the hearing on HP
225 and our next hearing is at 11:30 I
want to thank those of you that came in
and joined us today for helping us out I
appreciate that and uh we'll see you at
you
e
if you can fill out a card then we'll go
Sushi
represent labra you're doing the the 299
all right we'll go ahead and uh call
committee
meeting in session for a public
hearing regarding HB 542 FN relative to
weekly benefit amounts for unemployment
compensation representative McKenzie
would you like to present your bill
please yes thank you for the record my
name is Mark McKenzie I am the uh
representative from District 40 the
float out of Manchester I represent five
ws in the city of Manchester I'm here
today to introduce House Bill 542 FN
which is an increase in the unemployment
benefits uh and so I want to uh take
this opportunity to uh give you a little
background uh in terms of the
unemployment bill in general uh I was
looking at the when we came on board 19
1938 we paid $6 uh the first time on
unemployment benefits the UI system was
part of the the old age law which was
actually where the Social Security was
nested and so that it was part of this
process of providing a uh an an
underpinnings for the society in general
and the UI was an important component of
it excuse me so uh over the years uh the
system has revolved and and uh and here
we are today uh the system and as you
will hear from commissioner labors is a
uh joint is a partnership between the
feds and uh in the State uh essentially
the state has jurisdiction over the
benefits uh that are that are delivered
that was part of the handshake years ago
when the law was passed and the FEDS uh
keep all the money the repository is
down there the guidelines are all
provided through the federal uh the
federal law
and all the money is in DC somewhere so
let me say that um the preamble to the
uh to the unemployment law if you will
read the Preamble it was passed by the
legislature actually and what they what
it says is the general court declares
that the public good and the general
welfare of the workers of the state
require the enactment of unemployment
compensation laws providing for the
setting aside of unemployment Reserves
to be used for the benefit of persons
unemployed do no fault of their own and
for providing systematic accumulation of
funds During the period of unemployment
to provide benefits for the for for the
people so the purpose is in the Preamble
and the purpose is actually
twofold number one is to stabilize uh a
person who through no fault of their own
loses their job who needs the support in
this transition per period between one
job and the next and the second thing
this does is to stabilize communities to
keep uh workers connected in some ways
to the
employers uh and and this is uh this has
been what I've seen over the course of
the years
now a lot of people uh don't realize how
important unemployment insurance can be
but I've managed through my former
professional life I've had a lot to do
with layoffs uh big layoffs some were uh
as as large as six or seven 8,000 people
and that was when the wassaw paper mills
all went down and butf for the
unemployment absolutely nothing they
would have been in Berlin New Hampshire
and gorum New Hampshire you're not going
to put five or 6,000 people back to work
the second problem that you run into big
layoffs is that you have a Workforce
many times that is connected to certain
skill skill set and the the the problem
of trying to do a transition for
somebody for instance it was a paper
mill worker to a to a job in
high-tech uh is very difficult so you
hear a lot of times about well you can
just go out tomorrow and get another job
well when you talk to the paperworkers
up in the middle when it closed you ask
them what you want to do I want to make
paper well you can't make paper anymore
there's nobody making paper anymore so
it was a really difficult uh thing to
get them to a place where they
understood uh that they had to move on
now the the uh federal government along
with the unemployment office set up a
terrific operation up there but it it it
was a good example of what happens when
workers are in one occupation for a long
period of time the company closes and
then all of a sudden they they are out
and uh many times they didn't know they
were going to be out Wasa paper was a
good example of it so the unemployment
system comes uh when those kinds of
things happen and they do a number of
different things and one of the things
they do is to provide unemployment
benefits but also to provide this they
surround the worker with a system of
benefits opportunities to get them back
to work and let me say that nobody on
the unemployment system is a malingerer
you are not sitting at home on the
unemployment system system if you apply
for unemployment and and the
commissioner is here you have to show up
you have to call employers you have to
make sure that you uh that you're
connected and you're working hard so
nobody's sitting home which is a which
is uh sometimes what what people say
about the unemployment system now let me
speak to the specifics of the bill the
rate has not been raised uh since I
believe 2007 was the last time it was
done uh in um uh uh representative
infantine was actually on that committee
back then Russy Bridle I think was the
chair of the House labor committee and
they raised they raised the rate and
they brought it up in 2007 and there it
sits so it sits at
41,500 is the maximum income that you'll
take into consideration the maximum
benefit is
$427 now for the heck of it I passed out
uh something with the mean uh the wages
in the different areas so you have a
sense of what uh uh $4 $427 will
do uh and it doesn't do much and it
really has has it's a shame that we've
got so far behind the curve on this
particular
issue the other thing I passed out and
you at your leisure is to give you a
sense uh and it says that the top page
the number of continuous weeks of
unemployment and it also so that gives
you a sense of how many how long people
are out
uh on the number of of weeks actually
and then I'm sure the commission has
some stuff on the number of weeks people
are out but generally they're out around
12 weeks the other thing I gave you was
a uh local area unemployment static
because you need to understand that this
unemployment system Services people in
your district and this gives you a sense
of that so it's not just the southern
part of the state it's people all over
the state that are being affected by
this so when you put
427 which is the top benefit and you put
it against the average wage you get a
sense of how
inadequate this system really is not so
much for the bottom end of the scale but
clearly for the top end of the scale
because what happens with the benefit is
you hit 415 and you're done that's the
maximum benefit anything you make above
that you're not being compensating more
than
4415 so the the ratio replacement ratio
deteriorates greatly at the 415 level so
the people at the bottom end of the
scale are getting about 54% replacement
rate and it just goes down from there so
there are there are people in the higher
end of scale are in the 20% 25% rate
replacement wage and you'll hear some of
that what this bill does is to uh the
original Bill and there's an amendment
in process which I'll I'll have in my
hand by noon time I think
uh it raises the the top of the scale
brings it up so the the amendment will
bring it up six steps the original uh
Bill uh the bill that you see in front
of you brings it up 12 steps uh I talked
to the commissioner we had a good
conversation the other day and there's a
good reason why we want to stay within
that within that six steps but let me
say this that the only way you you're
going to be able to get beyond the six
steps uh is the way they got Beyond it
when they passed the the increase in
2007 which is you need to start looking
at how much is actually coming into the
system so there are two there is there's
a going out and there's a coming in and
uh the trouble with raising the rates is
that you bump up against this uh the
ceiling and you really not need to stop
thinking about the taxable uh base rate
because it's at 14,000 right now uh and
you need to start to think about
increasing that uh and you'll hear more
about this but inre in that to really be
able to provide additional benefits so I
think we need to be in the range of my
bill went up to
65,000 but we need to at least be in the
range of 55 or 58,000 because that's
basically where uh the average
wages uh but we're not going to get
there unless we raise the rate so what I
did was I uh the amendment will show you
this I I brought it back the commission
will give you some sense of people that
are cover
how that will affect people on the on
the scale his numbers don't relate to
necessarily the unemploy the uh
amendments but we did discuss it uh but
you'll have a better sense of that and
the commissioner and I have worked
closely on this people have worked with
the Department of Employment Security
and commissioner labors I know he's very
competent so with that I'm going to
yield to him and let him uh Dazzle you
with all the facts and statistics Mr
chairman I happy to answer questions now
or at the end of the hearing all right
thanks are there any questions right now
or do we want to get to the commissioner
first represent Sal just want to be
clear on this looking at at your the
bill as um introduced and um you said
that currently the um um it stops at 41
um five is that correct yes and uh
that's step 30 on here and you said you
added six steps in the amended version
so that would stop at uh 2,000 correct
right okay so the amended version would
increase it from 415 to 52,000 yes thank
you represent Flanigan thank you Mr
chairman so so you're not shooting for
65,000 you're bringing it down okay just
you and representative or uh Mr John
Amherst uh thank you chair kraton and
members of committee John Reynolds the
national Federation of Independent
Business of New Hampshire I'm the state
director of New Hampshire we represent
over 1,700 small employers across the
state um we did just I think
representative McKenzie touched on it
the toward the end of his remarks uh we
have concerns about this bill's impact
on unemployment insurance tax rates for
small employers well for all employers
uh because at least certainly as was
originally introduced and we haven't
seen the amendment language but as
originally introduced right it would
require significantly higher
unemployment insurance uh trust fund
Reserve uh which of course has to be
filled somehow and then in times of
economic crisis or distress the draw
down will be greater so this is going to
end up having an impact one way or the
other eventually on UI tax rates so with
that thank you the opportunity to
comment represent Flanigan thank you Mr
chairman as a former business
owner I didn't view unemployment tax as
a
Herculean obstacle in finance other
words it's it's it's based on like
$1,400 and the assistant commissioner
can fill us in
but that's only increases if the rate of
the unemployment tax goes up because I
we're below a level that we're required
to have isn't that correct yeah Mr chair
representative FL again it does float
based on the fund fund balance and there
are various factors that go into that
including your experience rating as an
employer right so if you're in a higher
turnover
industry this means a lot more to you uh
perhaps than if you're in a lower
turnover industry okay and the number of
you
and Mr LS please uh introduce yourself
and who you represent and we looking
testimony good morning thank you Mr
chairman members of the committee
Richard lers Deputy Commissioner with
the New Hampshire Department of
Employment Security um so in order to
fulfill representative McKenzie's high
expectations for dazzling you I did
bring stuff that has color on it that
might be the only thing dazzling that I
have um but I I did want to just um
quickly walk through some information
some important data points I think most
of which are familiar to the members um
that have heard prior conversations
around bills seeking to increase the
benefit amount and then um walk you
through some analysis that the
department did all of this is on the
bill as introduced none of this is on an
amended version which scales down the
benefits um obviously once that
Amendment comes through the department
will do an an analysis of that as well
um And to clarify the department takes
no position on the bill um we're here to
provide information answer questions so
I'll I'll get started I'll try to
quickly go through this um and I'll stop
at any point that individuals have
questions um so as representative
McKenzie had indicated current maximum
weekly benefit amount in New Hampshire
is
$427 that's been the maximum available
since
2007 um um whether you get that amount
is determined based upon how much you
earned in the four quarters prior to
filing for unemployment um and obviously
being unemployed through no fault of
your own uh there are 52 benefit tiers
uh they go from as low as $32 a week for
someone that had earned
$2,800 in their four quarter base period
to the
427 uh for which someone has to earn at
least
41,500 in that four quarter base period
lower tiers currently provide about a
60% wage replacement those upper tiers
are 53
54% wage replacement and benefits have
not been touched since 2006 which was
effective in 2007 and five additional
tiers were added at that point in time
uh what the original version of the bill
looks to do is to leave the existing
rates alone it does not touch the
existing tiers but it looks to add 12
additional tiers so starting above uh
415 which is that current Max earnings
that get taken into consideration and it
would start at 425 um with a benefit of
437 um and then it would go all the way
up to 65,000 and provide a benefit of
$669 um these proposed new rates
maintain the existing wage replacement
rates that are in the current statute so
53 54% wage replacement for someone that
is right at those earning
amounts uh when we move along uh to the
uh next slide I talk a little bit about
what the department has done to gauge
the impact of the proposed bill um so we
took the entire claim filing population
from both 2023 and
2024 to get a good flavor of uh regular
expected filing activity and what the
impact would be um we then took those
individuals that received the 427
currently and then parked them into the
new schedule uh that the representative
has filed um if you were someone that
was at 415 but not at 425 you stayed at
427 if you were at at least 425 you
would go into that new rate of 437 and
if you had at least 65 you would go into
that new weekly benefit amount of
669 so when we did that and then we uh
ran 2023 and 2024 as if the bill had
been in effect the impact on 2023 when
claim volume was lower um was about an
increase of $10 million in total
benefits being paid out so um current um
benefit schedule paid out a little over
35 million the proposed benefit schedule
would have paid out 45 million uh which
was about a 28% increase in total
benefits being paid when we did the same
to the 2024 population which there was
an increase in the number of people
filing in 2024 compared to the historic
low levels experience in
2023 um that was an increase of
31% um or a total of
14.6 million benefit payments going from
million the wage replacement rate when I
move to the the next slide and then in
some quick uh some data points the the
current wage replacement rate and what
we mean by that is the amount of the
earnings that you had while you were
employ in in employment how much of that
is replaced by your unemployment benefit
if you qualify for it if you're right at
that uh 415 right now like I said your
wage replacement rate is 53 54% so
you're getting about half that what you
were earning while you were working a
lot of incentive to get right back to
work but that's only if you're right at
that earnings earning level um what I
did was provide the the members with
some information on what the current
experience is for people that are
actually qualifying for that 427 right
now so you can get a sense of what their
real life wage replacement rate has been
so what your constituents are receiving
uh from unemployment in 2023 the average
base period earnings for people getting
that 427 was just over
$86,000 a year that's a wage replacement
rate of
26% in 2024 that average base period
earnings was about 88,000 885,000 so a
wage replacement rate of 25% so getting
about a quarter of what they had
employment looking at the impact of the
bill and the number of people that it
would have impacted when we we turn to
the next uh page in 2023 the bill would
have increased benefits for a little bit
over half the benefit filing population
or about 6,300 individuals in
2024 uh that would have increased
uh the benefits received by about
63% of the claim filing population or
about 8,200 individuals so those are the
individuals that would have been parked
in one of those new benefit tiers um but
had received 427 when they
filed um before getting into the
analysis on some of the the stress
testing that the economist in our labor
market information Bureau conducted I
just wanted to go over some data points
that are relevant I'll quickly go over
these These are good data points to have
uh for all of the conversations we have
around uh labor force issues um first
slide looks at a comparison of what the
change in private sector wages has done
since the last time benefits were
increased so you can see on the left
hand slide for the uh left hand of the
slide for the first one that has a chart
um that the average private sector
weekly wage in 2007 when benefits were
increased was $852
we fast forward to the most current um
records that we have are the second
quarter of 2024 that average weekly wage
private sector
1,453 when we turn the slide we can see
what that wage replacement rate is um in
2007 that wage replacement rate for the
average private sector worker was
50% in 20124 that wage replacement rate
is 29% for that average private sector
worker
uh next slide I look at the change in
inflation since benefits were increased
Ben uh inflation has increased for New
Hampshire about
42% um since the last time benefits were
increased a significant amount of that
is inflation that has increased over the
last 3 years coming out of the pandemic
uh when that's close to 20% of that
increase has been
experienced um return the slide I look
at how New Hampshire compared to other
states and how much we currently pay um
the first slide has all of the states
it's a little bit busy I did break it
down to just looking at states in the
Northeast um but nationally New
Hampshire currently has the 19th lowest
average weekly benefit amount at uh we
are at uh
367 um you can see where the other
states fall and including Massachusetts
averaging over $700 a week which is
second highest in the country when we
look at the next slide at just those
states in the Northeast you can see that
New Hampshire has the lowest average
weekly benefit amount um in New England
at 367 you can see where the other
states uh fall in in in comparison to
New Hampshire when we move uh to the
next slide you can see that uh New
Hampshire has the lowest maximum weekly
benefit amount that 427 that is the
lowest maximum weekly benefit amount in
the Northeast you can see how the other
states Stack Up um the only correction
to that slide is that the Massachusetts
amount is actually higher than that it's
actually over $1,500 now uh might be why
um I was reading an article in the globe
yesterday on the fact that without any
changes in the economy their trust fund
is forecast to be depleted in
2027 um and they owe the feds $2 billion
might be part of that reason when you
look at their their amount that they're
paying out um and then the next slide
looks at if the bill were passed with
the 12 new tiers that would put New
Hampshire at the 16th highest maximum
weekly benefit amount in the country uh
we flip to the next page um looking at
how that would compare with states in
the Northeast um if the bill were passed
with the 12 new tiers New Hampshire
would still have the third lowest
maximum weekly benefit available in the
Northeast um just higher than the state
of New York but lower than the New
England states when we look at duration
and exhaustion so how long people
currently file for benefits and how many
utilize all of their benefits um we're
talking about um right now an individual
New Hampshire unemployed through no
fault of their own they have 26 weeks of
benefits available to them on average
New Hampshire residents file and utilize
unemployment for 11.6 weeks you'll see
in this next chart that got rounded up
to 12 so I could get the numbers to fit
within all of our our small states um
and then the the next page looks at how
that average duration Stacks up with
other um uh uh other New England states
so our duration right now is 11th lowest
in the country um and it is the lowest
in the Northeast Vermont being closest
Vermont is just a a little bit over 12
weeks average duration
and we're at that
11.6 when we look at exhaustion so the
number of individuals who utilize all 26
weeks of their unemployment that
exhaustion rate for New Hampshire is
15% that's the second lowest exhaustion
rate in the country uh you don't have to
go very far to find the lowest and that
is our neighbor to the west uh with
Vermont at
133% uh the next slide I did the same as
what I did for other measures and
included just the new are just the
northeast states so you can see um how
that compares against those that are
closest to us and you can see the
exhaustion rates for New Hampshire and
Vermont are far lower than anyone else
in the Northeast and the United States
as a whole is is almost 40%
exhaustion um when we shift gears and
look at the impact on employers because
the unemployment program in New
Hampshire is 100% funded by employer
taxes um New Hampshire has the four
lowest unemployment tax burden in the
country the way they arrive at that the
um US Department of Labor Compares total
taxes paid for unemployment systems
against total wages paid in each state
and they arrive at that Apples to Apples
comparison despite a lot of differences
in how employers are taxed from state to
state so New Hampshire fourth lowest uh
tax unemployment tax burden in the
country when you flip to the next slide
you can see that it is the lowest tax
burden for unemployment purposes in the
Northeast um by far uh there is not
another state close uh to New Hampshire
um when Massachusetts is the closest
state to you from a tax perspective um
and they're still over three times your
rate um that just kind of shows how low
New Hampshire is right now for its
unemployment tax burden um when we look
at the next slide you can see actual um
uh experience right now now with
employers their average private employer
pays at
61% uh that equates out to about $85 per
year per employee for unemployment
taxes um and you can see that that is as
low as we were experiencing prior to the
pandemic and as low a rate that New
Hampshire employers have experienced
going back uh the past 30 years um
flipping to the next slide uh drawing to
the end of my comments um I get into the
stress test scenarios that are
economists in our labor market
information Bureau conducted so I asked
them to do three things one was to apply
the benefit schedule against their
existing forecast no changes no
recession no economic downturn and let's
see what happens when you apply this new
schedule compared to our current
schedule I then asked them to do model
it against a mild recession recession
like we experienced in the early 2000s
Uh current unemployment rate in
Hampshire is 2.6% the mild recession was
an unemployment rate of 4 and a half and
then we asked them to do a major
recession model uh Great Recession type
of scenario where unemployment in New
Hampshire uh goes up to 6 and a half%
which prior to the pandemic was as high
an unemployment rate as the state had
experienced so in the modeling under
current conditions I did uh put some key
takeaways on the next slide but if you
look at the chart you can see that the
current benefits that would be the
current condition of the trust fund
rather if no changes were made is in the
gry line the CH the trust fund
performance if this bill were in effect
is in the green line we started the bill
going into effect in the third quarter
of this year thinking that would be the
earliest that the bill if passed would
have an impact and then the key take on
the current forecast again no economic
downturn um in
2026 the bill would result in the trust
fund finishing the year about $21
million below where it is currently
forecast without any changes at 364
million in
2027 it would reduce the trust fund
balance by 33 million down to 353
million for a year-ending balance
important ly uh for that uh for our
prior discussions about uh the fund
balance reductions that are are are
keyed off of uh balance thresholds in
the fund for
solvency um it would not impact those um
it would come very close there are two
quarters in the model that would finish
um at 351 and 353 million
respectively that trigger uh for
allowing employers to get a one %
reduction on their rate kicks in at 350
million so when you're looking at a $350
$400 million account um moving the
needle by 1 million doesn't take very
much um so the forecast didn't call for
it to go below that fund balance
reduction um so uh I'm I'm just pointing
out that it was very close in each of
those quarters so current conditions uh
no change to the forecasted fund balance
reductions for employers
um mild recession again here you can see
gry line is without any changes what the
trust fund would do if New Hampshire
encountered that type of mild recession
Green Line being what the trust fund
would do with the proposed schedule from
representative McKenzie's bill as
proposed um key takeaways from that are
A $64 million reduction in
2026 A1 $27 million reduction um or
rather $87 million reduction in
2027 um there would be an impact on the
fund balance reductions in two quarters
employers um would not get the
forecasted uh 05 reduction to their
rates if the bill were in in effect
according to this
forecast that would cause an increase in
taxes to be paid in 2027 by New
Hampshire business of just over $26
million uh when we look at the last uh
scenario the major
recession um this is the problematic the
the even more problematic than the mild
recession um this would cause the fund
to go negative so there'd be no impact
on the payment of benefits New Hampshire
would continue to pay benefits we'd be
borrowing from the federal government
those would be loans that would have to
be paid back by New Hampshire employers
they may or may not uh have interest
associated with that depending on how
quickly they are paid back the way the
feds work that is that if you carry a
balance every September 1 interest kicks
in and if you pay it back prior to the
next September one you don't hit another
interest anniversary so it could or
could not have that level of impact um
what would so the takeaways from that
major recession are uh a $55 million hit
uh below the forecasted balance in 26
and then in 27 was when the fund would
go negative by $55
million um New Hampshire did go negative
during the Great Recession we borrowed
from the federal government in both 2010
2011 we did not borrow during the
pandemic um and the 2010 and 11
borrowing was paid back by New Hampshire
because of reforms that were enacted by
the legislature that increased um taxes
on employers um implement a waiting week
on claimants um and that was done fast
enough where New Hampshire was able to
avoid borrowing costs when they last
borrowed so a big hit on the fund in
that Great Recession uh scenario um
there's also an additional impact where
employers would lose out on fund balance
reductions earlier than under the
existing benefit schedule that would
cost them nearly another $23 million so
significant impacts uh with the major
recession
uh big impacts with the mild recession
um and zero impact on current conditions
uh but any Economist will tell you um
every seven years you can plan on an
economic downturn they just don't know
how significant it is going to be but
they all build in a 15% chance of
recession into their model um so I will
stop there and um hopefully uh bored you
enough right around lunch where there
not too many questions and uh we can go
from
there that as always that's great
testimony uh representative K and then
represent representative Alani thank you
Mr chair and thank you Mr labers so I
understand that uh there's an amendment
that would drastically reduce the impact
that you've just laid out for us is that
correct yeah I had um the SP
representative McKenzie did describe to
me what he was looking to do with
proposing six new tiers instead of 12
tiers but again I have not modeled that
or asked The Economist and elme to model
that I'll wait till the um the amendment
is provided and we'll we'll we'll do
that at that point okay yeah please uh
would you have an envelope that you
could do the back of the envelope uh
just sketch and give me some idea of We
Still fall off the cliff in the event of
a major uh recession um that I don't
know um I don't want to speculate I want
to run the the model the same way I did
um in this first instance and um it's
you know it's a pretty complicated data
query that I get from the system that I
set it up and then provide to The
Economist but now that we have it set up
we'll we'll turn it around pretty
quickly I can guarantee you that it will
have less of an impact um than the bill
as proposed whether it's enough to
prevent those fund balance reduction uh
losses um in the two recession scenarios
I don't know thank you okay
representative avalani
thank you Mr chairman thank you Deputy
Commissioner um just just to throw you a
little
curveball um if we set a top rate at 50%
set a top rate of wages and set a top
rate of reimbursements would that be
easier than all of
these scales within the the rsas and
whatnot would that be be easier for
obviously your department to forecast
but for tax for taxation purposes it
would be easier to
navigate just so I understand the
question correctly representative so
you're saying that if you set the the
benefit amount at
50% um so an across the board wage
replacement rate of
50% um having spent some time uh looking
at the 8,000 individuals who received
427 and
2024 the individual that re that had
earnings of just over a million dollars
were not going to want to place that
individual um at that rate um so there
would be the top uh
end where you have high income earners
um those um I don't remember the number
but you have a significant number that
were over
$100,000 a significant number over a
quarter million dollars um not very many
over a million dollars I think there was
one so um but you would want to be
careful um obviously you'd want to set a
Max similar to what social security does
right now um with the max amount that
they that they take taxes out um so
you'd want to have a Max uh Sim and also
similar to what the Paid Family Leave
program does they only provide a 60%
wage replacement up to the Social
Security uh taxable wage cap um so you'd
want to have something like that um but
um it wouldn't be any more complicated
than our current system some programming
would be required um but uh we can
certainly do that we have a a great
support vendor uh that does all that
work for us thank you and follow Mr
chairman for a followup um would that
also leave us in compliance if we did a
Model like that you know maximum amount
maximum salary maximum payout um I
believe it would we would we would need
to submit that to US Department of Labor
which I did fail to mention we have done
that with this bill as well we have not
got a response from them but uh I'm sure
they'll turn that around pretty quickly
um generally they they don't care what
the state sets those weekly benefit
amounts at uh they would caution any
state setting the rate at an amount that
they know is going to uh cause the fund
to be depleted because they don't want
to set up states to have to borrow from
US Treasury to pay
benefits um they as long as there
weren't any
differentiation um between um types of
unemployment types of Industry um my
guess is that they would not take issue
with it but again a lot of that would
depend on the solvency analysis as well
thank you follow follow um and also you
alluded to the uh interest rate dedu uh
reductions for employers would be
um going away uh with any type of
increase not going away but be harder to
achieve with any type of increase that
we have now um would you would you would
you have to look at having additional
triggers or maybe a smaller increase or
decrease at certain levels at more
intervals or a higher level of a trust
fund yeah it is
it there's only uh you know as I think
represented McKenzie's line was that we
we've got uh dollars going out and we've
got dollars coming in right um so when
you are increasing the amount going out
uh it does question whether or not the
amount coming in is going to be
sufficient to maintain a solvent fund um
the impact that the the bill as proposed
has is it
it it causes the fund balance to reduce
at a quicker rate because you're paying
out more and that causes the fund
balance to be lower in quarters earlier
than it is currently forecast under the
existing benefit structure so rather
than an employer receiving uh a the the
lowest fund balance reduction that they
can get it which is achieved if the fund
is at 250 million for for a quarter then
that next quarter employers get a half
Point reduction on their rate um so if
you're an average employer at 61 taking
a half point off that and bringing you
down to the minimum of 0.1 is pretty
significant um so that's what the
proposal does it causes the fund to be
lower earlier and thus the those fund
balance reductions are not achieved so
employers pay at their higher earned
rate rather than the earned rate minus
the fund balance reduction currently
your fund balance reductions these were
changed in
2021 um as part of House Bill 2 um and
that what they were changed they
previously it was at 250 million if the
fund maintains that balance for every
day of a quarter the next quarter
employers get a half point off their
rate if the fund maintained uh
275 million um employers received a
point off their rate and if the fund
maintained 300 million employers got one
and a half points off their rate the
change was um to the top two tiers the
first one did not change So currently
employers at 250 million they get get a
half point off their rate just like
prior to the change um and the top two
um the next one is 350 million employers
get the onep point reduction which is
where they currently are at um they have
been at for quite some time now for um
well over a year um and the fund needs
to maintain a balance of 400 million in
order to get the 1 and a half% reduction
and what those what those reductions do
they're they're like I described them
their solvency controls and they ease
the money coming in when the when the
fund is getting to those legislatively
established solvy amounts meaning we
feel the fund has enough to pay during
an economic downturn based upon recent
history therefore we're going to lower
the burden on employers and that's how
they function right now um we're at 391
million uh we're not forecast to hit 400
million we're forecast to stay in that
375 to 390 three range as long as
there's no economic downturn which Brian
golob and his team are not forecasting
um out through uh 2025 and into 26 um
but that's where we're at not forecasted
it hit that 400 forecast to maintain
that 1% reduction for the foreseeable
future thank you followup yeah let's go
with represent plan again then come back
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for yielding
um two things come out and there's
actually a third um but you addressed
one of them uh which is the trust fund
the trust fund will then be negative if
this bill pass to the negative 55
million am I not correct if New
Hampshire were to experience a major
recession event yes okay and may I
continue please um and now the
unemployment tax that is what our
employers are going to be paying uh
since they're now being come lower and
lower in the in the the brackets if I
can use that term they'll see a
subsequent increases of that thing but
according to your document with like the
fourth lowest unemployment tax in the
country am that correct correct fourth
lowest um unemployment tax burden in the
country okay and then do you have
another question I do thank would you
like to ask for that question yes Mr
chairman when I follow up with one last
question thank
you
um do you think people come to this
state or come to specific ific States
benefits that's not why I came to New
Hampshire um NE um I
I I try not to get into other people's
heads u i don't make decisions that way
I don't think most workers do I I think
they're looking for the right
opportunity um and they my the right
amount of everything else um but um
New Hampshire uh New Hampshire you know
we do border Massachusetts that has the
highest I know one of the highest
average weekly benefit benefit amounts
the average the highest maximum weekly
benefit amount um in the country I think
what second to Hawaii on that chart um
but there's no one in the country that
would tell you Massachusetts is managing
a good unemployment program um they came
out of their pandemic having uh made
what they described as an error to the
tune of $2.5 billion dollar and paying
people Fally Finance benefits when they
should have been paying them State
Finance benefits like New Hampshire was
doing so people like myself who sat
there during the pandemic watched weekly
payouts watched what other states were
doing New Hampshire was paying about 50%
of their benef beneficiaries State
financed benefits Massachusetts was
paying the about
90% Bly finan benefits
I knew there wasn't that much of a
difference in our labor forces and the
reason why people found themselves
unemployed we played by the rules we
depleted our trust fund down to about
$60 million and those are some sleepless
nights while Massachusetts did not I
like the fact that the US Department of
Labor is holding them accountable now
and requiring uh at least two billion of
that to be paid back but President Biden
did give them a break of $500 million
apparently in a Boston Globe article I
just saw but um um it Massachusetts
model is not what we need to achieve um
we want to maintain a wage replacement
rate that incentivizes people to get
back to work and I think most people
want to get back to work I wanted to get
back to work people I speak with that
utilize the program want to get back to
work so um but it's a matter of
adequately supporting them during a
reasonable amount of time to find that
next job thank you all right and
representative
Laing thank you Mr chair and this is
nothing short of dazzling by the way
this report thank you um just a couple
of questions what New England state has
the lowest unemployment rate in in the
Six States here um so New Hampshire
right now has the fourth lowest
unemployment rate in the country we are
second we are behind Vermont um in New
England uh Vermont is I think a tenth of
a point lower than our 2.6
um I don't think anyone any Economist
would tell you that there's any
similarity between the New Hampshire
economy and the Vermont economy uh their
labor force is shrinking ours is growing
um and our labor force is growing faster
than every other New England State
follow yes please and we have the lowest
uh average average benefit paid New
Hampshire does correct that's correct
and one more followup one more followup
so compared that to
Massachusetts do we see that there's any
type of motivation correlation here to
get back to
work well well I think Massachusetts
goes on the other the opposite side of
that right their average duration over
18 weeks um their average benefits over
700 bucks a week you can get up to 1500
bucks a week so that that's not the
model we would ever be looking to um
mimic here in New Hampshire um I I think
from a from a duration and exhaustion
perspective New Hampshire is is doing
um however looking at the population
that's currently getting that
427 um a wage replacement rate of of a
quarter of what you earned I can see
that being very difficult for people who
are legitimately unemployed you know not
they're they're not a bad worker they're
just in a bad situation they
legitimately want to get back to work um
and that can put them in a very
difficult position um with a with a
benefit amount that hasn't hasn't kept
pace um with with the inflation and and
purchasing power okay and one second
representative
stop um this is just a quick question um
I was just curious um on the um uh
projections that you did for the uh mild
recession and the major recessions um do
you have an
unemployment rate for what those would
look like yes so we um the UN employment
rate for the mild recession is
4.5% uh which was the rate experienced
in the early 2000s the Great Recession
uh the Great Recession the the major
recession that's
65% in both instances we took our
current labor force um and we took those
unemployment rates from those prior
experiences so current labor force prior
experiences um in term and then took the
increases that were actually experienced
at the intervals that they were
experienced um and um that's the the
results that you see and those numbers
that you see are quarter ending balances
um so each of those quarters through the
end of
okay thank you and representative La
last question thank you please um
administrative load there's going to be
a lot more people that want to collect
if this benefit is much higher is your
office prepared to handle that or would
you need to hire more people in possibly
a new bu to put them
in um great question first of all uh no
um our department has uh no needs for
additional staff um you know the
existence of an unemployment program and
and I know um Brian golob our Economist
has told this committee before the
existing of unemployment existence of
unemployment benefits increases the
duration of
unemployment but it's better than the
alternative um the existence of an
unemployment benefit to get you that
Financial bridge to your next job is
critically important
um while um we have low duration right
now and low volume um if benefits were
increased as long as there was an
increase that was in line with existing
wage replacement rates and didn't make
it easier for people to have longer
duration um than I would not expect much
impact on
duration when you increase
benefits
um Beyond in a reasonable amount which
we experienced during the pandemic when
the federal government kicked in an
additional $600 a week for the early
part of the pandemic about 30% of our
filers were making more on unemployment
than they were in their jobs prior to
the pandemic however they couldn't
work a lot of us couldn't some of us
worked a little too much um it was it
was a unique set of circumstances why
the federal government did what they did
but it also gave you a good example of
what happens when you increase the rate
too much um because what did employers
have to do particularly in the service
sector um I know representative avalani
experienced this probably as well you've
got to pay them more to get them to come
back to work and when you're paying uh
an individual to fold pizza box is at 18
bucks an hour the cost of pizza goes up
um and has an impact on
inflation and represent avalani thank
you Mr chairman just to just to come
back to the trust fund um typically the
trust fund is filled at what time of
year because we have the first 14,000
and then if there was any secondary lag
in the trust fund that goes down who
would be paying
that burden towards the third and fourth
quarter
yeah so good question so it receives
Revenue every quarter right the majority
of the revenue comes in as a result of
those first quarter reports uh so the
first quarter tax and wage reports uh
they come in in the month following the
end of the quarter so they have to uh
come
in um um in April um that's when the
majority of the revenue comes in because
most employers unless you have a
seasonal pattern to your hiring
um you're taxed on the first $114,000 in
annual earnings paid to each employee so
a lot of that gets hit in and um eaten
up in that first quarter some lag in the
second quarter and then new hires you're
going to have that uh could have that in
the third and fourth quarter and then if
you have a seasonal pattern you're going
to have more of it within whatever
season it is that you're hiring up for
but most of that um the over the
majority of Revenue comes in as a result
of the first quarter so we see that like
I said in April um and some some of
it will uh come in in that first week of
May thank you and my last followup Mr
chairman is that a quote that's the last
one all right go
Ahad um on the negative ratings uh we
have a positive rating employees we have
negative rating employers if the trust
fund were to move midcycle um
and the negative ratings were catching
up towards the end of the third and
fourth quarter in the first quarter
where most of us would file would get a
significant increase in our unemployment
insurance
tax um how would the department look at
that to mitigate that if there was
another recession that came through the
second and third and fourth quarters
that so we wouldn't be as you know where
I did anticipating a question from you
that was not rehearsed um I did look at
current amount that you're paying based
on each schedule um so right now
positive rated employers meaning we've
uh uh they've paid in more in taxes than
we've paid out in benefit so they're the
least risky to the program therefore
they are taxed at the lowest rate
schedule one you can have a rate as low
as $14 per employee per year you can
have a rate as high as
$364 per employee per year on average
they're paying $85 per employee per year
schedule two if you are newly negative
meaning that you just had an event that
caused uh layoffs you haven't had that
experience before so you've been
negative for less than four years
meaning that we have paid out more in
benefits than you've paid out uh than
you've paid in in taxes over the entire
life of you as an employer in the state
you start at a uh amount of
$392 per employee per year and can go as
high as
$910 per employee per year in the
highest uh schedule for those chronic
negative employers so those that have
been negative for more than four years
they pay from as low as
$462 a year
per employee to as much as 980 per year
per employee um there are adjustments
that can be made for those negative
rated employers because while they don't
get the benefit of fund balance
reductions they do get less of a sear
charge no positive rated employer gets a
search charge those were removed back in
2021 um so the highest rate that that
negative rated employer can pay um
results in a a tax uh per employee per
year of
1,50 thank you thank you Mr chairman
thank you sir are there any other
questions represent Flanigan thank you
Mr chairman I'm going to put you on the
spot Deputy
Commissioner what do you think of the
bill you have all the information you
have all the numbers going and I mean
you you you have the the rates you have
they're pay paid what the employer are
going to do let me reduce it down to do
you think the amended Bill covering like
a five versus 12 or whatever the number
is 15 might be a better
path I will uh once we're able to see
that and we're able to provide some
analysis um might be the way to go you
guys will get that um you'll be able to
take a look at it and um decide which
direction you want to go all right good
question so that being said uh I'm I'm
I'm very interested in seeing what that
six versus 12 means um we'll as soon as
we have that Mr chair we'll prioritize
it and uh we'll turn it around um I
think for my part of it it's probably a
day and then uh between the two
economists that worked on it probably
another day okay represent
Solan actually I was going to ask you
know what the time time frame would be
and um and perhaps we got to develop a
plan as to how we're going to move
forward with this because um it it seems
like we need that analysis we need more
testimony right and um so whether we
want to um bump this bill into um
another um hearing day um perhaps next
week and that might screw up the
schedule we just set up but yeah so what
we're going to do is we're going to
recess the testimony on this bill and we
will pick it up in the near future we
got some scheduling issues to go through
as you have some work to do so let's
coordinate on when we want to do that
right I think that's important for us to
understand the impact of what you're
what's being proposed is there any uh
questions on that any commment does that
make sense to
everyone represent when are we expecting
the
amendment uh represent McKenzie I
okay so we're expecting it soon and uh
we'll look at it for next Tuesday but
maybe the week after and uh I think
that's a a fair point thank you so much
for your preparation and your concise
testimony I appreciate
it all right uh this closes the the
hearing and uh we'll recess uh this
hearing until we
reconvene and we'll meet again back here
here at 1:00 thank you very
much one
one what do you think this is an
executive
lunch
e
started
all right and we have a COR 2 4 6 8 10
and 11 and represent stab you're going
to introduce this bill okay I'm like to
open the hearing today on House Bill
442 relative to prohibiting payment of
subminimum wages and representative stab
uh over to you please thank you Mr
chairman um good afternoon and I'm here
my name is Kathy stabb I represent
Hillsboro 25 um I'm here to present
House Bill 442 the sponsor was not able
to be here today um this bill in essence
would end the subminimum wage which is
mostly paid to tipped workers those are
restaurant workers waitresses servers um
also hairdressers and some other um some
other um classes of employees um the
subminimum wage is problematic for a
number of reasons first um the wage is
based not on the number of hours the
person works or the value but rather in
the case of a waitress that the the
value of the plate of food that they
happen to be carrying so let me give you
an example the the tip the uh sub
minimum wage in New Hampshire is
$327 an hour so if I um were to take my
granddaughter out for lunch and I had a
sandwich and she had a kids meal and the
bill came to
$20 um and I uh tipped at 20% the tip
would be 20 uh would be $4 and the um
the tipped wage from the employer would
be
$327 so if it was a quiet day and we
were the only people there then that
person would be paid uh
$727 for that hour of work if I was a
bad Tipper um and I only gave her $2
then the employer would be forced to
make up that money up to
$725 an hour um unfortunately for uh
tipped workers their wages can be really
variable but their expenses are not the
rent is still going to be the rent
regardless of how many people come in um
to the restaurant so that that's one
area that that's problematic the second
thing is that
um recently there have been a number of
high-profile um um cases where there has
been wage theft when people are paying
with credit cards then the employee has
to get that money from their employer
after it's run through the system and
there have been some situations recently
where um that money has not been turned
over to the employees so there are seven
states that currently have a a single
wage they don't have um they don't have
a tipped wage um they just pay the
regular minimum wage to whoever is
working there and then they get tips on
top of that um there are still
restaurants in those States a place like
Olive Garden still has restaurants
California where they do have one Fair
wage um so it's not
um you know it's it it's it's not a deal
breaker I think one of the things that
that I've noticed is that because um
because the amount the person is getting
paid is dependent on the cost of
whatever food they're bringing to the
table that a lot of smaller full service
restaurants with lower prices seem to
be um you know like we we had a Blakes
in Manchester that closed um they
couldn't find people to work there just
because people could not make enough
money off of selling sandwiches so um so
um there is some evidence that in states
where they have one Fair wage those
kinds of restaurants are more likely to
expand so that that's really all I have
to say on this bill if you have any
questions I will try to answer them um
this was not my bill so I haven't really
done a huge amount of research but um
there may be other people in the
audience that can also uh give you
questions represent
salv thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um is it the intent
of this bill to eliminate uh tips for
the the people who are earning at least
minimum wage no not at all um the the
expression is tips on top so a person
would be paid the minimum wage and then
um people would still tip them in states
where they have done this people still
do get tips and they are still making
restaurants okay wait a minute I okay
just to be clear because I I thought
that in your opening testimony it was to
eliminate the tipped wage okay the ti
wage is 327 so eliminate that and just
go with a St R minimum wage s and a
quarter which is currently seven and a
quarter right I'll be speaking to you
later about that I understand but just
okay so you want to you want to say hey
there's no 327 it goes up to seven and a
quarter okay gotcha thank you and
representative
La uh thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um is it possible
that this bill could lead to a decrease
in the Tipping culture uh tips on top um
and how would that how would customers
uh perceive the Tipping if they knew
that the employee was already getting a
wage do you think they would maybe tip
less that's a good question um I you
know there are seven states where they
are doing this um Maine for example
passed um a referendum a couple of years
ago that aimed to eliminate the tipped
wage um so that what what happens is
that the um the the tipped wage will
would would gradually increase until it
met up with the um with the the um with
the regular minimum wage um they're they
haven't reached that yet um their uh
their legislature kind of put a put a
slow roll on that but um in those seven
states where they like California and
Montana mostly Western States they they
they they still tip people I know I do
if I'm happen to be in one of those
States
yeah for a followup sir thank you
sir uh service quality with less
Reliance on tips for income might there
be um servers that may not try as hard
because they you know they they depend
on their tips right so they maybe give
you a little extra effort and oh my
goodness how would that square if oh my
goodness there is a whole body of
literature on the things that women have
to put up with because they are relyant
on that money to feed their children and
keep a roof over their head they are
constantly sexually harassed they are uh
mistreated by both uh owners and and
customers and one of the things that
this one Fair wage would eliminate is
what it would do is give um servers the
ability to say no you can't keep
grabbing me like that
I or I refuse to serve you because of
the way you're behaving so there's two
there's two sides to that
coin repr
K thank you Mr chair and I I apologize
for missing most of your testimony due
to the tight scheduling of our
hearings um does it seem right that I
mean isn't only understanding that
tipping is for service that if I get
good service I leave a good tip um and
if I don't get good service I leave less
of a tip or no tip and that um tipping
on the based on the price of the meal is
seems kind of unfair when you a waitress
in a a diner make we work very hard and
and work hard for the money as uh as I
heard in the song and uh and get small
tips mely because of the price of of the
meal that she's
serving yeah I mean the there's that um
I there are people here who know more
about this than I do but this the whole
idea of the tipped wage actually came
out of um out of
reconstruction um people um particularly
in the South and in other parts of the
country
um chafed at the idea of actually paying
black people who had been enslaved a
wage so they would have to rely on tips
in order to make any money so you've you
know you had Porters on the rail Road um
and um you know Barbers and anybody like
that rather than paying them a wage they
they would have to rely on on the
kindness of strangers if you'll forgive
me for saying that but yeah it really um
you know I think there's as much work
involved in you know in serving me and
my granddaughter that sandwich and that
um and that uh kids meal as there is in
bringing somebody um a $ 35 $40 stake I
mean they're they're doing the same
amount of work and you know the service
is probably just as good but because the
cost of the meal is so much higher then
that person would get paid more than
somebody who is working in in a in a
lunch place now there are two reasons
that one goes out to eat one is because
you know it's a special occasion where
you're going to be buying that $ 35 $40
steak and it's a it's you know you're
making an evening of it but then there
are those situations like you're a state
legislator and you've got half an hour
to eat and you didn't bring anything so
you need to you need you need to to find
someplace to eat locally or you're on
the road or you know and so you're
you're going to go someplace
where you just you just need to get
something to eat and sometimes you just
want to sit down and and at a table
you're you're you're not anxious to go
to a lunch counter um and you know and
that's the model that a lot of these
lower pric restaurants are going to now
where you it's counter service and you
you're your own waiter um just because
they can't find people to do the work
follow
up thank you for followup sir thank you
and and do do I understand that the the
the bill does not eliminate tips it so
it's still the incentive for the person
to do better than the seven and a
quarter current wage and receive a tip
for providing good service correct
correct yes so the $3 27 Cent wage would
go away and it would be replaced by
everybody getting whatever the minimum
wage is and currently it's said it's
$725 an hour which is the federal
minimum wage one more one more yes sir
thank you and representative would you
believe that I spent my lunch uh my
eating my my tun sandwich half of that
lunch time was spent talking with a
lobbyist and that was your
choice okay I'm just checking to make
sure
okay are there any questions
representative fton thank you what
effect do you think this would have on
the demand for labor with restaurants
difference
well it it's it's hard to say and and
I'm not going to try to speculate on
that I mean I think you know there is a
really there have PE people working in
restaurants have had a really hard time
finding people to come and work for them
and I think places like Blakes which was
an ice cream and sandwich place in
Manchester it wasn't you know there they
had a couple of restaurants but it
wasn't a big chain that didn't rely on
you know it was a neighborhood place
they they just couldn't couldn't make a
go of it because they couldn't pay
people um and and because the wages are
so um
volatile cuz you know if you go into
work and there nobody comes in you don't
get paid you get paid
$327 an hour or you know they'll send
you
home they have to pay up to
$725 for example if if you're working
for a full hour and nobody comes in then
you you're paid
$7.25 an hour your your uh employer is
forced to pay up to the minimum wage um
but I think that there would be more
stability for people who are working in
the restaurant industry um I think you
know it would make uh their lives um
more stable and think about the
restaurant and Industry as something
that's more viable rather than a stop
Gap or a second
job okay thank you and representative
Sullivan thank you um is it true that in
order to fill some of these uh positions
that are acknowledged to be hard to fill
um employers sometimes use a base wage
that's higher than 327 and in fact
higher than 725 in order to um uh fill
those positions and then again the
employees make tips on top of that um
elevated um base
wage I am I'm unsure about that but what
I will say is that
um most of the people that I know who
are people that I know who who I've met
through this um through this work of one
Fair wage they pay their employees $15
an hour um and but they and and the but
the model is different they don't go to
the table and take the um take the um
the order um they you know you come to
the counter and then they will deliver
your food to you um but it's the
everyone has paid $15 an hour and they
do all the work you know they Ser their
servers their prep cooks and they they
and Order takers and they just they just
it's they do everything and that's kind
of what I'm seeing more of as opposed to
going into Blakes and sitting down in a
booth and having someone come over and
take your order so I'm not really aware
of that other people in the room might
be perhaps
you I do believe that okay
representative Flanigan thank you Mr
chairman uh and thanks for testifying uh
hour that that's a good question
apparently there are 5,000 people in the
state of New Hampshire who make
$7.25 an hour or less um again you know
if you are a server and nobody comes in
during your shift you're making
$725 an hour other um um agricultural
workers are exempt from the minimum wage
also there's a law in the state that
says that you are um unable you're not
it's illegal to pay someone with a
disability who's in a sheltered workshop
less than the minimum wage so I someone
from the Department of Labor might have
a better understanding of that I was
unable to get that information but there
are five according to the Bureau of
Labor Statistics there are 5,000 people
in the state who make 725 or less follow
and for a followup sir thank you Mr
chair um would you believe that four
years ago that number was 5,000 5,000
employees
sure okay and representative labrin
thank you Mr chair my final question if
you don't mind are there any provisions
uh for a transition period to roll this
out I see 60 days here it would take
effect after passage that's a big wallup
to drop on any business owner that would
have a tipping situation um I could see
this driving the the cost of food
through the roof in 60 days which might
reduce some folks going out to eat just
a
thought uh well as I said I am not the
sponsor of this bill um like I and and
like I said I'm aware in Maine and other
states where they're looking to phase
out the tipped wage they're doing it
gradually and and I'm certain that the
the sponsor of this bill um would be
open to amending it to do
that okay thank you and any further
questions seeing n ma'am thank you for
your time and uh you can join us when we
value and sure if you can state your
name
and position for the record please yes
okay um so my name is Henry veu and I'm
here on behalf of the New Hampshire
lodging and Restaurant
Association uh and
nhlra is opposed to this bill um maybe
just by a quick show of hands who ever
worked in the restaurant
industry okay so we have some people
that are familiar with the industry um
so while the tipped employees and the
tip wage are included in the minimum
wage
statute tipped employees are by no means
at the minimum
uh wage in in and the lowest wage
earners if you go into a restaurant and
ask the folks that work in there um
whether they'd rather work in the back
of the house meaning in the kitchen at
an hourly rate with no tips or work in
the front of the house at the sub
minimum wage with tips they'll tell you
they'd rather work in the front of the
house um the tipped employees end up
bringing home the most take-home money
and they should they're the face of the
business they're the brand um they're
the Goodwill um so they should um but um
for those that the bill doesn't have the
statute uh it just says it's going to
repeal uh or just says um no rate can be
paid less than the than the minimum so
the statute right now says um that
tipped
employees those that receive tips um
must be paid at least
45% of the applicable minimum wage so
the
725 is the new New Hampshire doesn't
have a minimum wage statute we go with a
federal uh which is
725 um but if the if the wage was able
to go up um then uh 45% it would go up
with it um
so the the major obviously the majority
of money that uh tip workers are
bringing home are tips that's that's
they they they're it's taxed as income
uh so uh they have to uh file their
income taxes and those tips are
considered income um so it's it's very
similar to wages um in Maine uh to your
question uh what would the servers think
of this you know would they be concerned
about making less tips uh because people
would know that uh they are now making
the full minimum in Maine in
2016 there was a ballot question about
doing away with the tip wage it
passed a year
later um storm of tip employees showed
up at the State House for a 15-hour
hearing and they repealed it um the tip
workers would
rather I think have the system that we
have now um on average and this is
probably for a mid-range restaurant take
home 19 to 20 19 to 25 an hour um I've
seen some high-end restaurants in
Manchester where they're $44 an hour on
average when you take the tip wage and
the tips
combined um so again these are not tip
these are not the low wage earners and I
would ask you this too I know a lot of
them are probably working so they're not
here today but where is the swarm of
tipped employees that saying we need
this bill and have you gotten a lot of
emails from tipped employees saying we
we need this bill this bill comes up
every few years uh it gets killed um
there's a lot of misunderstanding I
think about the tip wage um they're only
getting 327 an hour um that's the
minimum cash wage that the employer has
to give them and they obviously make
most of their wages under tips it's been
like that forever um and this bill in
one full swoop will turn its on its head
um for a restaurant operator um I talked
with one who has uh you know places in
Salem Hudson Beford around the state
he's got a New Hampshire chain and the
current cost for his servers right now
under the 327 minimum is a million $1.4
million that's what he pays out to his
servers he's obviously got a lot of
servers he's got multiple locations
under this bill it would increase to 3.4
million which is a 60% increase in costs
and he can't absorb that much where's it
going to go the menu prices are going to
go up and menu prices going up people no
longer paying $25 for a meal they're
paying
$34 and they're knowing that the tipped
employees is getting the full minimum
and am I going to now go from 25 bucks
to you know I think the tips would go
down maybe some people would still tip
the same but you can't in increase the
cost and the price of a menu uh that
much and expect everything to remain the
same it just won't so we're opposed to
this bill uh and I'll answer any
questions thank you sir for your
testimony representive plan again and
then representa sylvestra thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question over here oh over here oh flan
again I don't I would probably take hers
first too no um
there's current discussion in Washington
DC about no tax on
tips so if we increase the base pay from
$324 to some number that's I in the bill
could in essence the tip wage person be
paying more income tax based on that
scenario conceivably if we're going to
uh not tax the tips and if we're going
to essentially do away with the tips up
here I mean people will still tip but if
they receive less tips up here I think
that's the point you're trying to make
is that they are now going to get more
of a cash wage from the employer which
will be taxable I think that's what
you're trying to say yeah mhm represent
sestro thank you and thank you for
taking the question you mentioned the
back of the house and that the front of
the house wouldn't want to be back there
can you just throw me out a figure of
what the back of the house makes on an
hourly wage um no one's making 725 you
can't find people for 725 Mike what
would you say back of the
house 18 to 30 bucks in the back you
know depends on the quality of the
restaurant yeah obviously I mean $30 is
going to be a high-end you know a Chop
House a copper door you know the
high-end that's where the $30 is going
to be and those servers are probably
make the servers are probably doing 44
an hour with the tips so
followup yes ma'am thank you all right
and it's been said over time that the
weight staff supplements the back of the
house is that true or false I'm not sure
I understand the question in other words
their tips are taken and then given to
the so uh the labor department will come
down very hard and there have been
restaurants that have learned the hard
way okay tips uh they can be pulled
among um uh uh the other servers but um
you can't take tips from the front of
the house and give it to the dishwasher
or the cook uh because the labor
department will come down very hard okay
that's what I believe to okay I'll wait
in case anybody else has anything go
ahead floor is yours and then
representative
McKenzie first represent D sylvestro and
then representative McKenzie go
ahead all right this is democracy
represent McKenzie the floor has been
yielded to you thank you thank you Mr
chairman
um there have been changes in the
federal law uh the regulations changed I
think last year or the year
before and it the the change is as it
relates to how people who are serving
when they come off the serving clock and
when they go back on the serving clock
which I think is going to be quite
frankly pretty problematic can you give
us some sense of what that how that's
playing itself out in restaurants and
maybe
explain a little bit uh about what that
regulation is yeah so I think you're
referring to a situation where server
gets uh called in um maybe it's not busy
early on uh so they are not they're
doing maybe rolling the silverware in
the napkins or whatever so the labor
department um the ruling you're speaking
to uh is about what wage do they get
paid when they're doing uh that kind of
work um is it the 327 or the 725 or
whatever the applicable minimum wage is
in the Gibbon State um and so
um Mike might be able to speak to Mike
Summers from the Restaurant Association
Summers if you could uh join at the
podium introduce yourself and then uh
thank you Mr chairman uh for the record
Mike Summers president CEO of the New
Hampshire lodging and Restaurant
Association so representing mcken Dan
your question you're talking about the
8020 rule the 8020 rule essentially
requires that 80% of a server or a
tipped employes time must be used
directly waiting on tables or customers
whether bartending whatever it might be
and 20% of that time could be used for
incidental activities that are
supportive of that uh service that
you're providing um there was a change
under the Biden Administration that
added a 30 minute cap that you couldn't
have them doing incidental work for more
than 30 minutes um and then that was
taken up by the courts and has since
been overturned so we're now back to the
old rule of the 8020 rule if that's
question or followup yes
sir so how do you how do you manage that
in a
restaurant how do you how do you manage
to I'm working 80 % and 20 how do you
managed
that I'll be frank and honest it's not
easy um but frankly the 30 minute cap
actually made it even harder because we
had a scenario where you would and this
is just as an expectation of of an
employee so an employee would come in
they would clock in they would work for
30 minutes at uh tip wage because that's
the 30 minute allotment that you could
have and if they weren't done with side
work or they didn't have any customers
yet they'd have to clock out clock back
in at 7:25 uh then when they got a
customer they'd have to clock out and
clock back in at 327 then they'd have to
work their shift and at the end of the
shift they'd probably have to clock out
um and and and switch around and and I
will tell you having managed restaurants
that it's hard enough to get them to
clock in and out let alone have them
clock in and out six times in a shift um
so but frankly to answer your question
the way it's handled with the 8020 rule
is if a if an employee Works a six- hour
shift we just have to make sure that
they're not spending more than 20% of
that working on things other than
waiting on staff um again it's a little
bit of a you know Loosey Goosey but
you're trying to keep track of it as
best you can based on hours and business
and those kinds of things and for those
of you who have worked in restaurants
many of you know that there's always the
early shift they come in a little bit
before you really open to customers they
do the opening side work they leave
early and then the other group comes in
there the closing shift they work their
shift and then they'll do the closed the
shut down stuff at the end so it's
always kind of rotating and there are
ways to kind of Safeguard to make sure
that we're not taking advantage of our
employees okay uh one more represent
McKenzie
thank you um so I've heard over the
course of the years uh numbers kicked
around about what actually White staff
is
making there is a
um there is there are a number of people
who say that tips are being cash tips
are being in the pockets and nobody's
reporting that do you have accurate data
to back up these what you are saying in
terms of what uh employees are actually
making can I go to the Department of
Employment Security for instance and ask
them to pull data based on weight staff
and uh would it support the numbers that
you're actually talking about the 17 18
$20 I think years ago when cash was used
a lot more often um I mean you think how
many how often do folks here use a lot
of people it's on the credit card so
there's a record uh whereas um
you know with cash to your you know your
explanation of pocketing uh the money um
I asked um one of the operators uh
for no names on this thing um and he's
got these are these the he's got the
tips and the cash wage and the number of
hours and calculated it uh the average
uh hourly rate and the bottom you know
you're down at like $19 an hour and the
top is $44 an hour this is this
is uh the cash wage and the tips
combined over the hours they worked um
and that's what you get divide you
divide it up and
so $19 to $42 an hour uh is the range
you know depends what shift you get um
what day you get uh whatever you know a
bunch of variables
but representative solvan
sir thank
you I don't think OLS office of
legislative Services did us a great
favor in the way they structured this um
there's a huge chunk that should have a
strike through through it so we could
all look at it and see what fell out of
the stat
um and I think some of the testimony
earlier Got U caught up in some of that
lack of a strike through I I think there
was testimony saying that um um as the
minimum goes up um the 45% will be a
bigger um chunk of money do do you
recollect that a few years ago there was
a Senate bill that came through that
established that 327 would be the tipped
wage regardless of whether the federal
um minimum wage goes up or not so uh
you're a couple years ago there was a
bill that passed that said if the
federal minimum wage goes
up New Hampshire's cash wage for tip
employees would remain at
327 but that doesn't preclude the state
of New Hampshire at some point in time
um setting its own uh C minimum wage and
cash wage for tipped employees so it
does if the feds go up um to your point
um the 45% doesn't apply uh but I but I
would State this another point that uh
the restaurant operator pointed out to
me um he increases his menu prices about
3% a year and tipped employees get tips
on the price of the meal so over time 3%
a year 3% a year there's already this
built-in factor that helps tipped
employees wages go up because they're
based on the price of the
meal you just for clarification so today
under current
law the tip wages are indexed to the
federal minimum wage so um at 45% well
so New Hampshire doesn't have a minimum
wage la
uh we default to the federal
725 and the bill that we were talking
about there's a section I wish we I know
I wish they had the strike through like
you were pointing out yeah so there's
the the RSA on the minimum wage there is
a separate section that was passed a
couple years back that said if the
federal minimum wage goes up new hampsh
the
45% uh won't apply to the federal
minimum wage that New Hampshire's
current 45% of 725 now 327 if the feds
go up we're going to stay at 327 that's
what passed a couple years ago okay and
that's what's on the books today that's
what uh okay fa enough Mr chairman if I
may it actually doesn't say any of that
what you said makes a lot more sense
yeah um but you have to read it four
times to figure out exactly there's two
separate paragraphs that deal with
the 725 or the U federal minimum wage
and then one of them says 45% the the
second paragraph says um it stays at
three um it doesn't say it stays it says
simply says it is
$327 it OS didn't do us a favor there
either I agree with you very confusing
when you read the statute
okay uh represent avalani and labry and
then D Sylvester I got you thank you Mr
chairman um in in regards to what was
just discussed um I think we uncoupled
the 45% from the minimum wage um and we
separated out the tip wage from the
minimum wage in case the minimum wage
ever went up it was always an argument
that you know 45% of
$15 so we uncoupled it so it maintained
the 327 in one statute and it maintained
our minimum wage Statute in a different
statute explain well thank you thank you
thank
you representative lry thank you Mr
chair uh thank you for taking my
question sir what level of animosity
would this bill cause between the front
and the back of the
house in terms of one getting a raise
and one
not yeah I mean I I I uh what would the
impact be I think you probably see
something similar to what happened in
Maine I mean again for the folks that
this is going to benefit have you heard
a lot from them no because I don't I
think this is a solution looking for a
problem and I think what reaction could
there be you probably have those tip
workers coming here next year asking for
that build this build to be
repealed represen D
sylvestro thank you I was just curious
when you were throwing out the S uh
hourly wages do they receive any
benefits in a restaurant for those
numbers $18 $20 $40 an hour uh it it
varies widely um and it also depends on
whether they're full-time or part-time
Etc you know in many cases the $19 is a
part-time employee um they might be
making as much as 30 or $35 an hour
working 30 25 or 30 hours a week so um I
would say that it varies by company and
it varies by their category within that
company all right thank you followup yes
ma'am thank you and then when you talked
about um the pricing going up it's
actually the consumers here that in
increas so we're
supplementing the wages by tipping based
on what the the customers are paying for
yeah yeah okay all right that's it thank
you representative hasing thank you Mr
chair and thank for taking my question
um I have read some articles in the past
that New Hampshire was the number two
leading um in the amount of tips that
are given to a server is that actually
true and could you validate that
information for me or give me some of
that I think I read the same article I
believe it to be true um there are some
various Publications that kind of rank
States and I will say that the states in
the west that have higher wages and then
tips on top of are the lowest tippers in
the country so I think it's fair to say
that you know yes we have more generous
tippers here I also think Co had a lot
to do with that I think uh folks were
were very sympathetic of our industry
and we certainly appreciate that but but
I believe those numbers to be pretty
accurate
yes okay representative mclair thank you
thanks thanks gentlemen for uh taking
our questions do you know what the
percentage of the of the tips that
servers make have to be
claimed under IRS rules it is
100% really yes now um having worked in
the industry and waited a lot of tables
and bartended Etc um there are certainly
some cash uh tips that are forgotten in
the general processing of your cash out
at the end of the night but it
technically it's 100% okay quick
followup if I sir it and it's been a
long time since I've waited on tables or
bartended you know since 30 Years anyway
um I kind of remember it being 50% but I
mean that so they would basically take
you know what you sold 50% of that or or
multiply by 20% and then take 50% of
that is that kind of the same how they
do it or uh no because back when you and
I waited tables um we were actually like
physically Cashing Out nowadays it's all
processed to the POS system
um but what I will say is that uh what I
think you're referencing is the IRS has
kind of A Safe Harbor and the business
can have an agreement with the IRS that
they will declare no less than 75% of
the you know credit card tips Etc in
order to be essentially
um exempt from be receiving an audit um
and there are mechanisms that they have
to take that the IRS makes them follow
in order to be able to to do that but
ultimately the IRS standard and the
business owner you know Advocates to
their employ emplo you must claim 100%
of your tips because ultimately it's
income and is therefore taxable one more
quick pH yes sir so did did they do that
by your amount of sales
and yeah I guess right so I guess did
they claim like say okay the average is
tip is 20% your sales were $300 tonight
so you made no so it again in the age of
credit cards almost everything is credit
cards now um and they see it they know
they they know exactly what it is so if
you got a really great tip over here and
a not so great tip over there at the end
of the day the number is the number um
and usually what the IRS and the
business owner will look at is that
provided you're not less than 75 or 80%
of what that total credit card tip
number is you're probably okay that's
kind of how it works all right thank you
good question represent d
sylvestro one last one I just want to
know if a any one of us or are in a
restaurant to you to the question about
the Tipping and it's cash I pay the
credit card for the bill can I tell that
server to pocket them I don't know if we
can say that on can I tell that server
to uh I want that specifically for them
in their pocket so you're you're saying
you're putting the the the dinner bill
on a credit card and cash is tip you
don't have to tell
them kind of I wasn't sure if they had
to say
it all right see one more question
representa avalani thank you Mr chairman
um we are required to withhold um tips
and claim tips uh could you tell us to
structure how that is the employer pays
half the employee pays half but the
employee also has the ability to claim
above and beyond and who would be
responsible for
that wait can you ask that question
again loed question we are responsible
for paying half of the uh claim tips and
the employee is able to claim above and
beyond what we've claimed given our
basis which would come down to cash tips
you're referring to the tip credit
correct
okay you really want to go down this
road so so the what's that brief oh I
don't know if that's brief so the tip
credit essentially is how the business
owner actually gets to the 327 right so
essentially they have to prove to the
Department of Labor the IRS and others
that they have that the employee has
collected enough tips to be well over
the 725 and then there's a credit of $5
and whatever the number is $5 in change
that is then essentially deducted from
their hourly wage requirement so
essentially you're technically paying
725 but you're taking it back as a
credit because they made enough tips to
then receive the credit so it's it's
almost like a you back into the number
if that's a fair characterization I
don't know how to better explain it
slideshows all right representative Hall
how many what percentage of employees
fall into that category where they would
725 honestly Henry asked me that
question a minute ago I am my 16 years
here and you know 20 years in the
industry I have never heard of a person
actually have to be reimbursed for
making not making minimum wage on tips
not once follow so in other words this
bill is not going to make the difference
between somebody getting to 725 or not
nope no thank
you okay seeing no further questions
thank you for your testimony thank you
and it's Mr Solan right I will fill out
yes I'll thank you sir appreciate it and
I'd like to the next
um wedness is uh
Mr ver
verer oh miss vender I'm sorry thank you
mcken is one of those names can go
and your your who else is testifying I'm
just here for support by C me I'm just
here with Macken I'm not speak okay all
right fair enough hello my name is
McKenzie verer I live in Manchester New
Hampshire I'm in support of this bill um
I've also worked at Mr Max an untipped
restaurant for about 3 years and I
worked at an Olive Garden for about a
year um and I just want to correct
something that the previous testimony
said um servers do actually have to tip
out their busers um at least at Olive
Garden the restaurant that I work at the
busers will make a uh uh the minimum
wage seven what is it 725 725 the
servers will make the sub minimum wage
and they will have to tip out their
busers whereas people in in the actual
back of the house like the uh the cooks
will make about like 17 to 20 and
dishwashers will make about 14 to 15 so
I just want to make sure that
distinction is clear um at Olive Garden
I never heard that it was like illegal
or wrong that's just what
was done um I also want to say that no
27-year-old mom trying to feed her kids
will be mad if you give her a raise no
one is going to be up in arms about that
people deserve to be making a minimum
wage I've seen people I was a Hostess so
I made uh $14 an hour but people deserve
to be making a livable wage and 725 is
an livable wage we all know that I mean
I'm sure everyone in this room makes a
lot more than that um I make a salary
position and I'm still struggling um and
then with my experience working at Mr
Max where we didn't earn tips we all
made like 12 to $14 an hour people still
bought the food Mr Max the prices were
expensive but I can tell you from
working you know on a Saturday night
that people are definitely still willing
to pay whatever the price is for that
food and we all made $14 an hour and we
still got tips um there were shared tips
cuz it was you know but we uh we served
them we bust them and we're all happy um
this is just my real experience and I
want you to know that I wasn't working
in the restaurants 30 years ago I worked
there last year um so yeah this is this
is what real life looks like that's all
I have to say thank you no thank you for
your your testimony I appreciate you
coming in are there any questions
representative labry thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question do
you believe that if you were to give the
servers at where you work a $4 raise to
to make minimum wage ballpark
do you believe that the rest of the
folks that work in that same restaurant
in the back of the house the dishwashers
the management do you believe that they
would also expect a $4 raise no because
they're already making more they're
still making more the people in in the
back of the house like they said they're
making 15 the minimum wage everywhere
else they're not making 725 um so maybe
at certain restaurants but I can also
like most people who work at a
restaurant know the experience of being
a server and it's hard work being yelled
at being being disrespected being spat
at you know um so no I don't I don't
think so but who knows follow up for
follow up thank you Mr chair the reason
I would ask that is is I own several
businesses and and I know that when I
pay one employee a little bit more than
the next it goes through the company
like wildfire and everybody has to get a
raise if I pay one person something so
uh it was just a consideration I didn't
know I'm out of the restaurant industry
for a while and I didn't know if that it
might play the same way so you've
answered it I think in this circumstance
it would be slightly different because
this would be a law that would change uh
the the uh pay not uh the manager
deciding that someone deserves more so
no I don't think so good point thank you
okay and representa K thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question am
I correct in understanding that the
people working in the back of the house
who are already making more than seven
in a quarter are paid that same wage
regardless of their customers in the in
the front of the house or if it's snowed
or any other negative uh economic that
might slow down the the the serving yeah
absolutely that's their wage they make
$15 an hour no matter who's there follow
up yes sir um thank you again and is it
also correct that in most other
businesses other than the restaurant
trade you pay your wages you pay
everyone the same wage based on their
skill or what they do and you don't
expect the customer to directly pay part
of the wage for instance if I had a
factory I wouldn't think my the end user
who buys the widget is going to pay
directly my uh factory
worker um I can't answer that question I
don't own any businesses and I don't pay
people so I'm I'm not sure I quite
understand the question I would just
follow for followup yes sir I would just
trying to explain the difference between
uh a tipped worker being paid the where
the customer is expected to pay the wage
is probably more than half the wages and
that's unheard of in other
employment okay yeah I yeah I definitely
understand yeah another point I wanted
to raise is the idea that this is the
way it's always been why have we ever
thought about that why when no under
other industry pays their their workers
like that why do we do this does that
kind of answer a little bit I'm thank
you thank you
representative Mackenzie thank you Mr
chairman thank you for appearing today
when I'm trying to uh nail down and
you're an experienced weight staff we've
heard all kinds of numbers about what
you make um now you worked at Olive Gard
yes that's a pretty busy restaurant yes
um the state uh lists the average wage
uh at $20 an hour for weight staff it's
the average wage the lowest age that
they list in the Unemployment uh uh
figures is is
1144 which number were you closer
to um so again I was a hostess I wasn't
specifically a weight staff so I was
still paid hourly but I my friends were
not making $27 an hour I mean maybe if
you're you know more if you're an
experienced server you might be making
20 an hour but I really doubt it most
people my age would probably be making
with their tips like 15 uh to 19 an hour
but I haven't done the math so the would
you like a followup yeah real quick
absolutely so the the range then uh is
from 11 to 20 that's somewhere where
where weight staff is dropping in that's
what I would assume yes all right thank
you thank for all right thank you ma'am
I really appreciate you coming in and
all right seeing no further questions
and no pin cards I Clos the hearing on
HP
442 we've got about five minutes so what
I wanted to do if you can indulge me
real quick it's a very special
day one of us in this room is having a
birthday and it's it's his 30th birthday
and I I think we should sing happy
birthday if you could join I'll turn off
my
you okay we'll adjourn or recess here
for about six and a half minutes we'll
link up again at 2 o'clock for the next
you
e
session on uh House Bill 726 FN relative
to the state minimum wage or minimum
hourly
rate and representative St or you'll be
ucing this
Bill yes that's correct thank you okay
and if I can get a pin card from you
when you get done oh yeah sorry
I I will do that okay all right ma'am
the floor is yours all right thank you
good afternoon my for the record my name
is Kathy stab I represent Hillsboro 25
which is Ward five in Manchester and I
am the sponsor of this the prime sponsor
of this bill um and I'm here to
introduce House Bill 726 which will
raise the state's minimum wage and
increments to $15 an hour by by
2028 uh this is a modest bill that
increases the wage to $10 in September
1250 in 2026 14 in 2027 and 15 in 2028
it also sets the tipped wage at half of
the minimum wage the last time New
Hampshire raised the minimum wage John
Lynch was governor in 2008 the average
rent in the state for two-bedroom
apartment was $1,000 $1,044
and today a two-bedroom apartment rents
for
$1,800 times have changed and things
have gotten a lot more expensive and
most states around us have responded by
raising their minimum wage the lowest
minimum wage in New England is Vermont
at
$141 Maine is at
$14.65 Massachusetts and Rhode Island
are at 15 and Connecticut's minimum wage
is set at
$16.25 the Bureau of Labor Statistics
reports that about 5,000 people people
in the state make 725 or less the
economic policy in um Institute
estimates that there are about uh 61,000
workers in the state who make $15 or
less who will benefit from this increase
I've given you a chart from um the
economic labor market whatever it is
elmi that shows that some of the occupa
some that show some of the occupations
that have starting wages below $15 they
are mostly people working in Food
Service retail child care and home
health aids these folks are an important
to the economy of the state and the
quality of life for all granted Staters
and I believe that it is important for
us as New Hampshire's elected government
to demonstrate to the working people of
our state that they are valued and that
this is and that is why I would urge you
to send this to the house floor with an
autopass recommendation and I will take
any questions that you have thank you
ma'am I appreciate your testimony thank
you representative ly
thank you Mr chair and thank you again
for taking my question could you tell me
what industry predominantly holds the
seven and a quarter workers where would
they work what industry is that I can't
tell you because that information is not
available but as I said earlier um um
agricultural workers are exempt from the
minimum wage um people working in
sheltered workshops who have
disabilities are the are required to be
paid 7 25 an hour um and um on on those
occasions when um tipped workers do not
make um the minimum wage then they are
technically working for 725 an hour um I
would love to know that information um
perhaps we um I can find out from the
Department of Labor or perhaps from the
um um uh Department of Employment
Security but I have not been able to
find that information this comes from
the Bureau of Labor for statistics okay
thank you okay thank you representative
bshar uh thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative for taking my
question now wages have gone up in New
Hampshire without a minimum wage so why
is it necessary can't we just rely on
the free
market that's a very good question thank
you for asking that um yes wages have
gone up significantly in the state of
New Hampshire but it didn't happen
organically not not not in my estimation
for example the fight for 15 campaign
was a large national campaign that
involved millions of people who
advocated for $15 minimum wage um every
one of the states surrounding us has a
much higher minimum wage and um as you
know we're a physically very small state
and I would say that 80 to 90% of our
Workforce can drive an hour in any
direction and be guaranteed uh minimum
wage of 14 or $15 an hour just by
crossing the border into another
state thank you for a followup
sir wouldn't a higher minimum wage
reduce Reliance on public
assistance ultimately saving taxpayer
dollars that yes people who are because
things are so expensive particularly
housing is ridiculously expensive people
um are paying um more than 30 to 50% %
of their income for their housing so
they need to rely on things like food
stamps um and um housing vouchers and
other things like that so if people were
making a living wage which is around
according to the um MIT living wage
calculator single person would need to
make
$23.58 an hour to be able to pay for
housing food and incidentals um and um
so yeah though so people who are making
less than that at places like Walmart or
or wherever um are receiving um those
companies are receiving corporate
welfare because their profit margins are
higher because they're paying so little
at the dollar store um but those people
are forced to um use food stamps and um
Avail themselves of other um Public
Assistance okay thank you representative
Dro I just want to follow that up I I've
had a few examples of employ employees
over the years who have had public
assistance and uh so they can only work
a day or two a week otherwise they lose
assistance so and I've even talked to
them and said well if you work all five
days you actually make more money you
just won't get the assistance and they
said no no I'm just going to stay with
my two days a week so can you speak to
that because in my mind it doesn't
matter how much money you make if they
know that they can only make x amount
they'll just work under that so even if
you raise a minimum wage does that
um yeah well I think what you're talking
about is the cliff um so that if people
make more than a certain amount of money
they lose benefits so yeah that that
that's definitely something that's out
there so I think people uh talk about
raging that raising the threshold for
benefits but if a person is making
enough money so that they can fulfill
all of their needs then they don't need
they don't need the food stamps they
don't need the other stuff um so I mean
there are um when I looked at the elmi
report I was really astounded by the
starting wages that are well below a
living wage and how many people and how
many different um occupations are making
less than $20 an hour um you know I I
put together a list of some of the
lowest paid
occupations um I use median wage instead
of um minimum wage you know that means
that half of the the people in those
occupations are making less than that
um you know so Hostess like Mckenzie was
telling us about earlier the starting
wage for that is 1171 in the median
wages
1533 child care workers starting wages
are
$127 an hour um fast food counter
workers $12 u18 an hour um
cashiers um um home health aids $14.30
an hour that's well below what um people
need need to actually
um pay for their basic needs you know
food shelter and incidentals so you know
I um and and let's face it going from
7:25 all the way up to to 15 is going to
make a big difference but yeah I I know
that there are people like that you know
I have um yesterday I was in the grocery
store and one of my favorite cashiers I
think she must be close to 80 um and um
I'm sure she's on Social Security and
she seems to be there a lot but I I
can't you know I don't know how many
hours she's allowed to work there and
and still keep her social security
payments but that's not enough for her
to to to um pay for her daily needs so
she needs to
work I think she enjoys it but you know
represent
Flanigan thank you Mr chairman and uh
thank you for taking my question sure so
is this bill dealing with the minimum
wage or is this bill dealing with uh
livable
wage um this is a a minimum wage bill um
I would love to see a working uh you
know people making uh living wage but if
the minimum wage in the state is 725 and
a living wage is $20 an hour certainly
uh TW the the gap between um $15 an hour
and $20 an hour is much smaller than the
gap between
$11.9 an hour and and what you actually
need to live which would be uh $20 an
hour followup for a followup so
basically I guess my question really is
that is this bill mislabeled then
because you're talking about sustainable
wages that is what someone needs to live
whereas minimum wage is someone who's
never worked a job someone just out of
school or in school that working so I
guess what I'm saying is minimum wage is
not a liable wage we all agree to that
so why is this bill why are these bills
labeled increase in minimum wage then
because you're talking about sustainable
wages because a living wage in New
Hampshire is
$23.58 an hour for an adult with both
with two P for two adults both working
with two children uh it's $29. 34 an
hour and that's not 15 so 15 would be a
minimum wage and um because 15 is not a
living wage and that's as high as it
goes okay representative
King thank you Mr chair um question for
you uh I looked here on the numbers from
the other states did you do any um
information or look up anything on
specific impacts that the minimum wage
increases in these states have had on
whether it's the cost of those goods in
those businesses or anything like that
to see if there's any increases in that
when the wage went up um I
um I did not include that in this um
however new Hampshire has the 13th
highest cost of living in the
country um and we have one of the lowest
minimum wages I mean our minimum wage is
lower than Arkansas where where they
have a much lower cost of living um so
we are already pretty high in terms of
cost of living um I think we're we're
closely aligned with Maine Maine is
interesting because like 10 years ago
when I first started looking at this
issue our minimum wage was 725 and
theirs was like
$783 an hour and then they passed their
um they passed the the ballot initiative
that began to raise their minimum wage
which is now up to um um uh
$14.65 an hour and it was interesting to
watch what happened with both economies
and they're pretty much have followed
exactly the same track um the um average
wage in New Hampshire is a little bit
higher but the number of people making
very low wages in Maine is is is not as
many as we have here in New
Hampshire and it's so I don't think it
really I
mean I mean you looking at the housing
costs in New Hampshire there nobody I
can't imagine and that's a huge part of
person's expenses and there's no place
in the country where it's worse than it
is here in New Hampshire so I you know I
I so I don't think I I didn't see
anything other than you know we we also
heard you know Vermont is very similar
to to us in terms of unemployment Etc
there hasn't really been any kind of
negative impact on Main's
economy their unemployment has stayed
pretty low the the growth in the economy
has been
sustained and for a
followup yes thank you um so as far as
you you pointed out Maine a couple times
here do you know the actual people that
were the amount of people that wages
increased in that that have you done any
research on that I have I didn't bring
it with me I am happy to send that to
you the the main U main
c um which is the equivalent of what our
New Hampshire fiscal policy Institute
they did a big study on what happened
what what the first thing that happened
was that the poverty rate went way down
in the state um but I certainly have a
lot of information about um the impact
of of course it was so long ago that I
might not be able to find all of it but
there was certainly some reports on how
um what impact raising the minimum wage
in the state of Maine had on their
economy and on the quality of life of
the people who live there thank you
representative bashard thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question now how can we justify not
investing in our workers well-being when
studies show that increased wages lead
to improved productivity and reduce
turnover well yeah I think one of the
big ISS one of the big hold um one of
the things that's holding our economy
back is that um we have a shortage of
workers the people who are most impacted
by the minimum wage are people who are
just starting out in their careers
because they're you know they're making
those entry level wages if those are
lower then um young people might be who
are not attached in the community are
more likely to leave the state and look
for work
elsewhere um and um you know neither of
my kids live in New Hampshire
um you know in terms of of of of just
having a stable Workforce having a group
of people who can afford to pay for
their living expenses and not have to
worry about losing their apartments or
um not being able to fix their car when
it get when it breaks down so they can
get to work um a higher higher raising
the the the floor of the people who are
struggling fiscal policy Institute
reports that a third of the people in
the state according reported to the
United States s census that they are
having a difficult time paying for
everyday expenses so if we enable people
to pay for their everyday expenses and
feel like um they have a decent quality
of life and that they don't have to
worry about um what will happen to them
if their car breaks down or they you
know they get evicted from their
apartment um then you have a more stable
Workforce and those people are are are
here to stay they're um invested in
their work work place and in their
communities thank you representative lry
thank you Mr chair uh just a couple
final things uh I just wanted to clean
this up if I could the what is the
average demographic of the person that
makes the 725 was it in fact young kids
or is it adults in in apartments or we
weren't able to figure out what sector
these folks worked in maybe we could
figure out what age they are I like I
said I have no idea we have been trying
to find out that information for 10
years okay we we only have that number
the the the number of workers at each um
wage level that um the 10 12 and
$15 marks that information cames from
comes from the economic policy Institute
and they were able to find that
information but that 5,000 person number
comes from the Bureau of Labor Labor
Statistics and it seems to be kind of a
black box and I mean if you ask um
people from uh the Department of
Employment Security or whoever um you
know
they they they they spoke to this kind
of issue a couple weeks ago when we were
talking to them that you know that
people people issue quarterly reports
with how many employees they have and
and how much they how much they're
spending on salaries but they don't it
it's not broken down as far as I know
and I don't know if uh there isn't
anyone here from Employment Security and
there is someone here from Department of
Labor but I would be willing to bet that
they don't know either that's okay
understood one follow up or followup
thank you Mr chair um say we went ahead
and and passed this law and we set the
the minimum wage here in the state of
New Hampshire at
$15 um and then we had a massive
recession and we had to lay off folks
because we we didn't have the work um
would it be best to let you know the
organic process of capitalism and supply
and demand take its place or do you
think we should
be beholden to that 15 even if it means
the whole ship goes down with the so to
speak ship goes down with the uh the bad
recession we ran well you know we've had
minimum wage in the United States since
the 1930s and 40s or 50s or you know
it's been around for a long time it was
something that um Franklin Roosevelt was
very invested in so I mean we've been
through a a lot we've been through ups
and downs and we've had a minimum wage
and the minimum wage used to be a lot
closer to a living wage than it is now
um I think if um you know we just spent
uh a lot of time talking about what
happens during a recession and how there
is um um stop Gap measures for um people
and that the federal government will
also step in and help in a period of
severe recession
so I think
um ensuring that that um people are are
paid a a wage that allows them to live
with dignity
um I think that that that's really
important I I you know as as the minimum
wage has gone up it really hasn't been
something that
um that you know there's studies that go
back and forth sometimes you do lose a
few jobs but then you get more jobs and
people who had been working two jobs are
now only working one job um so it
appears that there are fewer job there
are few people working but they're um
they're actually only working one job
now and before they had to work two or
one and a half um no I I I think you
know paying somebody a living wage or
paying
someone uh
something paying people a wage that um
reflects their value and that and the
the fact that they are contributing to
the economy and to the society I think
you know we should we should do that
cuz when you're paying people who are at
the bottom end of the economic scale
more money they're going to spend that
money it's not going in the bank they're
not going to buy a yacht going to spend
it you know they're going to go out and
get a pizza they're going to stop and
get um a coffee the next time they buy
gas they have a little bit of extra
money to spend and you know like the the
situation we have now is sort of like a
tornado where all the money gets scooped
up and then sent to the Top This is a
way of keeping it down at ground level
so that it can um so it can you know
stimulate the
economy okay represent
Hall so if you set a minimum wage for an
employer that has say 20 employees say
it's a small landscape company or a
restaurant or um whatever and you tell
them they have to start paying their
employees twice as much where does the
money come
from
well first of all
um it it's not automatic it I mean
that's why we're doing it over a period
of years first of all right now um wages
are are fairly High there are people
that very like as you pointed out there
are very few people making 725 an hour
in order to get people to come to work
you're paying more than that this is
really very modest I would say that you
know if you look at these numbers here
um when the when the minimum wage goes
up to $10 there are 10,000 out of the
600 close to 700 or maybe more than
700,000 working people in the state who
will be impacted by that who will get a
raise from that at the most when you get
to $15 an hour it's going to be about
on10th of the workforce
so the thing is that you know if if
you've uh if you've got a business and
you've got 20 people working for you the
likelihood that um you're paying them
$15 an hour or less um in this
environment is is is pretty unlikely so
the idea that going up to $15 three
years from now
um is you know you're going to be
doubling people's salaries is pretty
unlikely with these numbers I mean if if
you know if you were paying people 15
and the minimum wage went up to 30 well
then that that would be this this is
based on on being modest and thinking
about how businesses are going to cope
with the increased minimum wage thank
you
represent representa Hall go ahead thank
you um just to be clear though leaving
the specific numbers out if you're
telling employers they have to pay more
you're either assuming they are just
banking larger profits than they deserve
or they're going to have to pass that on
is that do you agree with that well I
think if you're you know there are
places that that that pay much less than
they you know I I think of large
corporations like dollar stores they're
the worst they pay the lowest salaries
of anybody and I think you know those
people that are working in those stores
absolutely deserve more money than
they're getting um and and so that would
be the case I mean most small
businesses they pay their their they
they work you know cheek to Jal with I
mean they're doing the work too I mean
it's not it's not like Darden
corporation that owns Olive Garden and
whatnot it's you know it's you know it's
somebody that um owns a local lumber
yard or or has a small restaurant or
whatever they they know they're
employees and they try to pay them as
much as they can um and so in those
cases I
mean because of the way the environment
is now and where wages have already gone
up so much much um this is incremental I
think um you know yes sometimes maybe
prices will need to go up like in the
dollar stores the these dollar stores
that come into communities and knock out
you know the local grocery store and
they knock out the local um um you know
the the local you
know for mostly the grocery stores but
other little stores and and and small
businesses and then you know they're
they just don't provide the same level
of service and and you know and the
person who owned the grocery store the
hardware store um they no longer can
make a living because they've been
undercut by this large corporation
that's nowhere near New Hampshire that's
paying the people that they came into
the community that undermined
um they um yeah they should pay more
they absolutely should pay more okay are
there any questions um represent
farington and then Drago thank you so it
seems like 61,000 people be affected by
this at this point right now if firms if
employers are willing to pay those
61,000 people at $15 or below isn't it
reasonable to think that at the higher
price of 15 firms would be less willing
to pay those people and so that
unemployment would increase
um
that there have been um a lot of
analyses um uh Mark Twain once said
there are three kinds of lies lies damn
lies and statistics so uh you know
however you want to read the the stuff
there are cases where you know I think
um the Seattle and Tacoma Airport area
they raised their minimum wage um they
didn't really see there were two people
that looked at the the data and decided
two absolutely different things that um
uh employment went down employment went
up but I mean if you look at these other
New England
states there they you know the EMP
unemployment rates have still stayed low
I mean when when Maine started raising
their minimum wage there wasn't a huge
spike in unemployment in fact it's it
has been at 3% since they started doing
it it hasn't really varied much at all
so as people were getting paid more they
weren't laying people off in fact the
economy was growing because more people
had more money to spend in in a
consumer-based society that's that's
what happens all represent
Drago a quick question yeah really quick
thank you Mr chair I'm just curious you
mentioned obviously it's a tight labor
market that drives prices up uh right
now if anybody has a pulse we're hiring
them for 20 $25 an hour um during our HB
238 hearing we heard a lot about um if
you don't like the union portion just go
find another job you referenced um the
dollar stores and stuff like that not
paying a lot my question is why can't
those people everybody's hiring why
can't they just find a different job why
why are we so focused on a job that
doesn't pay a lot because if nobody's
going there they're going to have to
increase their rates
anyways well one of the things that
happens when Dollar Stores come in in is
that they drive out the other businesses
because their prices are so low you know
if you're if you run a a community
grocery store um and you know you're
bringing in fresh produce and you know
it's a family family-owned business um
it's hard for you to compete with their
their prices because they can buy in
bulk and they don't
pay the people that work there very well
so they drive out the businesses where
other
people had had worked
before and then um then the only place
left for them to work is at the dollar
store and then they get really
underpaid that's one of the things that
that happens and so you know I always
hate and they they tend to go into
underserved communities where people are
um you know are are are already
underpaid and and you know they're
they're attracted by the low low prices
but then in in doing that they're they
drive out the other
community um centered businesses where
they could work for more money but they
wanted those
cheap um whatever things that they sell
at the dollar store okay thank you thank
you so much for introducing this bill
seeing no further questions I'd like to
call Dr Kenny please okay and I pull out
a pink card for you thank you thank you
Kenny Kenny yes Reverend Dr Gail Kenny
please thank
welcome so good after Mr chair and good
afternoon Mr chair and members of the
committee for the record my name is Gail
Kenny I am a resident of Kanan New
Hampshire and I am here speaking here on
behalf of the New Hampshire Conference
of the United Church of Christ so for
the whole denomination of uh known as
the UCC or the congregationalists and um
the United Church of Christ is the
largest Protestant denomination in New
Hampshire um and in our 13 cities and
221 towns there are over
130 um UCC or congregational churches
and so um the our denomination back into
2014 um passed a resolution the whole
denomination imp uh calling upon our
churches to come before you and implore
the New Hampshire legislature to pass um
a to reinstate the minimum wage for New
Hampshire and to move toward um the
minimum wage being a living wage and so
just a couple of things um so we hear
about the market working well the market
works except when it doesn't and so the
idea of setting a floor below which we
as people of um of decency below which
we should not go as a state in terms of
valuing work whatever the work is and
whoever does it um a minimum wage is
meant to be a floor and um so we the the
um United Churches of Christ um are
asking the legislature to create a a a
reasonable floor for when the market is
not otherwise working so I just want to
um address sort of a couple of of myths
first is um when the the concept of a
minimum wage was first established on
during in the the FDR the Roosevelt era
it was never intended to be a training
wage it was meant right from the start
to be the bare minimum that people that
working people would need and families
would need in order to survive and so
just a couple of things so somebody has
been asking questions about um
demographics and so this is from the
economic policy Institute what people
generally think part the myths are that
minimum wage is just for teenagers or
minimum wage is for somebody who stepped
into the Working World for the very
first time minimum wage is only for
people who work uh part-time kids who
work part-time after school or who live
with their parents or people who just
want to earn uh extra spending money in
the early days of going to these
hearings I remember people referring to
or some legislators referring to isn't
this just for pin money for people who
want extra the reality is and again from
the um economic um policy Institute is
the people in New Hampshire who would
benefit from an increase in the minimum
wage getting up to the 61,000 that were
referred to um if the minimum wage
reached 15 um dollars an hour just
working up to from going from 10 to
15 the average age of the person who
would benefit is 35 years of age um 90%
of the people um who would benefit are
not teenagers they're 20 years of age
and older 59% are women 28% of the
people who would benefit have children
and uh 54% of the people who would
benefit work full-time so that's the
reality those are the demographics that
have been studied um
so I think that we all know I think that
we all share an understanding that um no
one in New Hampshire can Thrive not just
on 7:25 an hour but on $10 an hour on
$11 an hour on 12 um dollars an hour
based on the cost of living in the state
of New Hampshire and again the churches
the 130 churches that are you know do
practically the land Cape all over the
state if there's not a United Church of
Christ Church in your town there's one
in the town next door um we are all
saying to you pleading with you this
should not be a partisan issue this is a
matter of basic decency and basic
morality and um in this recent past
election I think that on the um at the
national level you may all recall um
that a big part of the um the
conversation was the price of grow
groceries and the even the um the new
president has said that groceries is a
beautiful word and groceries helped him
talking about groceries helped him win
the win the election um so I would again
to each one of you to look in your heart
and to ask you for somebody making $10
an hour now somebody making $11 an hour
now in our nursing homes the people who
are taking care of our children and
taking care of our parents or our
grandparents um and the people people
who were serving Us in the in the dollar
stores for those who frequent those
um let us let this state say as a matter
of public policy that we will pay enough
so that everyone can afford the price of
groceries let the price of the cost of
living in New Hampshire be what guides
us to create a moral floor below which
this state says we will not go because
we value all work so thank you very much
for your consideration of this bill I
hope that you will find um HB 726 ought
to pass thank you man' appreciate your
testimony are there any
no representative labry thank you Mr
chair I'm just looking at the way that
this scales over the next four years at
10 12 14 and 15 yep does that track with
inflation and is that enough or should
more um well in order for people to
really survive it should be far more
than that but this bill is trying to be
reasonable to create a basic floor so I
would have to you know just to be honest
with you I do look at these statistics a
lot and I know the folks are the
economic Justice Ministry of the United
Church of Christ looks at these numbers
all the time I don't have the inflation
numbers I'd have to really look at them
and I could certainly ask you about that
but part of what this bill is trying to
do is to make up to to get us to a point
where we're closer to a
floor so that people who are making the
10 11 12 or even the people of making
the 5,000 people that are still making
725 are not living in abject poverty or
constant economic anxiety when work
fulltime so if you need the statistics I
can I can try to do that an analytical
you thank you and representative Hall
please uh thank you for taking my
question uh would you be in favor of
making the minimum wage in New Hampshire
not I think if we were really serious
about the value of valuing work
and an understanding that all work has
dignity in the state no matter what it
is and no matter who does it um that we
should take a look at what it takes to
survive in the state of New Hampshire so
that you are not living in constant
economic um anxiety so that you can
afford even a one-bedroom apartment and
you can afford to clothe and feed your
children um if you are one of those um
you know a wage earner who's trying to
um support a family I don't think that
the cost of living requires that to be
$50 an hour yet but I do think if you
look at the statistics that 50 uh $10 an
hour gets us closer than where we are
now $15 an hour gets us closer than
where we are now so that we don't have
an escalating homelessness crisis in the
state of New Hampshire and so we should
care about all people in New
Hampshire even those For Whom the market
is not working should be able to have a
roof over their head and put food on the
table and the an anal analytics now tell
us that that's about 20 or $21 an hour
we're not saying that it's it
realistically New Hampshire doesn't move
that quickly and so what this bill is
trying to do is to get us to someplace
better than where we are
now thank you so much and seeing no
questions thank you ma'am I appreciate
your testimony again thank you so much
sir and I'd like to call uh Viola
ma'am good afternoon uh my name is Viola
ksim for the record and um I'm here on
behalf of the gr State organizing
project we are grassroot organization
that's best in um in manchest but we
represent different regions uh Upper
Valley uh the mil soan Valley um and the
the other pieces of the hillsbor county
um and our goal is really to bring
people together uh we bring uh Faith
communities we bring people that are
interested in economic Justice and also
uh fairness uh as well as labor unions
and the goal is to make sure that we are
working towards a New Hampshire that
allows people to thrive um and so we're
here to support uh HB 726
um on the notion that this support is
not only from gsop but also uh we've
seen policies that lift the wage flow
being supported um across New Hampshire
uh in May 2021 there was a poll that was
commissioned by the public policy um
polling and of that they uh they pulled
voters in New Hampshire and they found
out that 63% of New Hamshire voters
voters supported a gradual increase of
the minimum wage to $15 an hour by 20
25 um of that section of Voters that
were pulled uh six
56% were in support of increasing the
subminimum wage that we just talked
about in the last bill to $15 an hour by
2027 so this is not just um something
that's not supported wide wide uh not
Statewide but it is it has a lot of
ground Roots uh support and I can just
add on to say that um this last election
we went around uh in different
neighborhoods uh speaking with voters on
a nonpartisan issue just kind of trying
to figure out where people were and what
they cared about um we talked to nearly
10,000 bers I knocked on 10,000 doors
and talked to nearly 1,400 bers and of
all the people that we spoke to um the
biggest uh concerns were housing costs
child care costs as well as health care
costs um and uh several of them talked
about how wages were very low in New
Hampshire um so this is again something
that keeps coming up in most of your
districts if you haven't talked to your
constituents you should um and so I want
to highlight U some of the studies that
have been mentioned earlier um the New
Hampshire the National Low Income
Housing Coalition which is a national
advocacy group uh that works around
housing mostly cering to people that are
extremely low income um has studies out
there and they indicate that a worker
that's making $7 and 25 cents an hour uh
they need to work 140 hours a week if
they want to afford a one-bedroom
apartment at market rate which is around
$1,300 a month um and um for that um uh
the the actual uh housing wage for New
Hampshire is around
$25.33 according to the national income
housing um
Coalition and so for for one bedroom so
someone has to be making a around that
that wage to afford a one bedroom in New
Hampshire uh and we know that our
current rate of 725 cents an hour uh we
are very far from
that um I also want
to highlight that uh when I was uh this
was back years back when I was um
working at one of the stores Macy I used
to make $88.50 an hour and at the time I
used to take every shift that was
available and sometimes closing until
like midnight um and I just remember
working I didn't have a life and I was
the I was I was an individual I didn't
have a household I didn't have anyone to
support it was just me paying rent and
paying my costs uh living cost and I
just remember working non-stop to get
every shift that I could so I could pay
my rent um and
so that is the reality I know a mother
through the conversations I was talking
about earlier that we had talking to
people on the doors uh who's making $10
an hour and. 50 and she has two kids and
lives in a a one studio apartment uh
with her two kids so that's the reality
of people in New Hampshire and that's
why when we say raising the minimum wage
does benefit families we are not talking
about just single people we're talking
about we're not talking about teenss
we're talking about families um and so
I'm just here to encourage the committee
uh to consider raising the minimum wage
and supporting this Bill thank you for
your time thank you for your time thank
you for your testimony uh any questions
seeing no questions thank you ma'am I
appreciate you coming down and talking
to us thank you I'd like to call Mr
Trumble please state your name and who
your affiliation yes
sir hello Mr chairman and committee
members my name is David Trumble I'm
from the town of whereare um I'm also a
small business owner I support this bill
for few reasons first is the question of
economic dignity you can't live on
minimum wage or you can't even live on a
little bit more than minimum wage nor
support a family you've heard the
numbers so New Hampshire is way out of
touch with the rest of the country it's
not just all the New England states that
have higher minimum wages this year
alone in 2025 23 states are raising
their minimum wage in Missouri in the
last election 58% of the people in that
state voted to raise their minimum wage
to 1375 they just did it and going up to
$15 next year this is not just the New
Hampshire versus the rest of New England
we are out of touch with the entire rest
of the country it's not just the people
who earn the very lowest wage that would
be benefited by this but also it would
set a floor that would help the people
ear earn a little bit more than the
lowest I know that in my own business
you want to have good workers you pay
them a little bit more than somebody who
just starts with with you so if you have
a minimum wage that means people who
make a little more than the minimum more
than what you're paying your starter
workers would get up so that means
people who make 15 16 17 $18 an hour
would benefit from this as well this is
people at the lower end of the of the
bracket you asked for some statistics
about New Hampshire there was a study
specific to New Hampshire done by the
nonprofit organization Oxfam America and
they reported this I'll I'll hand in
written testimony it was in public news
service July 30th of last year they said
that more than 130,000 New Hampshire
workers would benefit from a raise in
the federal minimum wage and that it
would include the more than 20% of women
in the state who earn less than $17 an
hour who make up the bulk of the state's
child care and Elder Care WorkForce One
in every five women in this state make
less than $17 an hour if you pass this
bill you will be helping 20% of women go
to the grocery store on your way home
tonight one out of every five women you
see would benefit if you pass this plan
and these folks are struggling to
support their own families and that
Oxfam report also said that the
overwhelming majority of low wage
earners this is New Hampshire are over
the age of 20 you already heard that the
other thing that comes up is the
question of what's the economic impact
of raising minimum wages and you heard
their studies that go this way and that
way I'll just leave you with a few that
would suggest that it would be
positively beneficial first is it helps
economic growth this study um was done
by uh the center for American progress
in 2023 they looked at the 30 states
that have minimum wages higher than the
federal wage which is what we have and
they looked at their recovery from 21 to
23 they had a
38% industrywide growth double that of
the states that used the federal minimum
wage with a 19% growth so other words
when you have a higher minimum wage you
have more money circling through your
local economy if you have the money
somehow gets divided up in this country
into pies if it's going to the very
richest people it's not staying in New
Hampshire if you give more wages to the
people who work in your communities
they're going to spend more of it Henry
Ford found that out he raised wages when
he set up the first automobile plant a
100 years ago so that his workers could
then turn around and buy cars there's
other studies somebody mentioned
turnover in productivity this was done
by the center for economic policy
research and they looked at data over
the last 30 years and they said that
actually it is more cost effective for
employers to pay a higher wage because
they don't have to retrain people as
often if you pay a decent wage you'll be
able to keep your workers that in the
long run increases productivity reduces
the cost of retraining and then the last
question was one about does it cause
unemployment this one is from the
quarterly Journal of economics in 2019
they looked at 37 years of research
comparing States and they also look at
counties that are like between states
and they found the overall number of low
wage jobs remained essentially unchanged
five years following an increase in
minimum wage and the union leader just
had a report on this in January 5th of
25 and they they cited a 2015 study from
Dartmouth College that a minimum wage
hike would have not likely have
significant negative effects on
employment in New Hampshire so in other
words what I'm trying to say is that if
raise the minimum wage you're going to
have more money circling through your
local economies it's going to benefit
the people of New Hampshire the
government is always making economic
decisions we're trying to get a $4
trillion doll tax cut mostly through the
wealthy through the federal government
that's the first item on the agenda we
just had a big tax cut 180 million in
New Hampshire the interest and dividends
tax most of which went to the wealthiest
people in the state the government is
always putting its thumb on the scale
the question here is are you willing to
put your thumb on the scale said we're
willing to help the people on the lowest
end of the income scale I think it's
time for New Hampshire to catch up with
Missouri and the rest of the country
thank
you thank you sir for your input and
your testimony appreciate your time yes
sir see no questions from the
committee thank you and if uh the last
couple speakers could provide their
written testimony we would appreciate
that uh Dr Kenny if did you have written
testimony you didn't
seber thank you representative
appreciate it you coming yeah thank you
thanks for being here today everybody my
name is Christine cyber and I'm from um
I represent Hillsboro district 21 which
is Ward one in
Manchester and I just wanted to add a
little bit to the conversation here I
just wanted to say me and my
constituents fully support this
legislation um when I go around and talk
to my constituents um I often talk to I
don't talk to you just because you have
a d behind your name you know I talk to
anybody who's outside working in their
yard that type of a thing and this issue
very specifically has been brought up to
me um you know just with them bringing
it up not me instigating that um that it
has a lot of bipartisan support um from
across the board it's it's a big issue
to a lot of
people um and then also I just wanted to
bring up having worked um for minimum
wage before um back when it was like 525
or something an hour um but um the often
the jobs are very labor intensive they
also involve um a lot of customer
service um face Toof face with customers
that type of thing um and it's often a
very like you know not the most
conducive environments it's it tends to
be underst staffed so it puts a lot of
work on the workers so these folks work
really really hard and I would just like
to add that you know it would be helpful
for the overall morality of our society
to do this um and I believe worker in
output will also be affected in a
positive way um so thank you and I hope
you support this legislation well thank
thank you man I appreciate your
testimony any questions from the
committee see no questions I appreciate
Isel and if you could state your name
and who you represent please yes um I'm
Claudia stelle and um I'm representing
myself but I'm also a member of the
economic Justice Ministry for the United
Church of Christ in New Hampshire um and
thank you for letting me speak this
afternoon um I'm here to support the
bill um as a person of faith I believe
that every worker deserves respect and a
living wage for so their Labor uh for
their labor so that they can provide for
the basic needs for themselves and their
family food clothing housing
communication Transportation Medical
Care and education um um I I have
submitted this in the portal so I'll try
to summarize there are four points that
I would really like to bring to your
attention one is that today the federal
minimum wage remains at the same level
that it was in 2009 at
$725 an hour there are 5,000 workers in
New Hampshire who earn um at or below
the 725 an hour there are 10,000 who
earn less than $10 an hour 19,000 who
earn less than $12 an hour and 61,000
who earn less than $15 an hour that's
nearly one in 10 of workers in our
states and not all of them are teenagers
ear working for their first job I'm a
retired teacher and I know that many of
my students um were working while they
were in high school because their
parents expected them to be able to take
on um paying for their clothing their
school supplies and even to contribute
to the family um bills
um the second thing I'd like to point
out is that if a worker was working 40
hours a week 52 weeks a year which is um
the maximum that they could work at a
minim at the minimum wage they would be
earning
$15,804 they would be earning
$2,080 a $800 a year and even at $15 an
hour it's
$31,200
um the federal poverty level in 2025 for
an individual is
$5,650 which is more than what you're
earning at the minimum wage so the
minimum wage as it currently stands as a
poverty wage and even for at $10 an hour
um the wage the poverty level for a
couple is
$2,150 so again that's still a poverty
wage um we know from the MIT um living
wage calculator that the living wage for
a single person in Coos County is nearly
$19 an hour and in Rockingham County
it's over $25 an hour almost $26 an hour
um all the other counties fall in
between that but the point is is that um
it's two and a half to three and a half
times what the minimum wage is to have a
to earn a living wage in the state of
New
Hampshire um so so this this bill which
proposes raising the minimum wage to $15
an hour in in in increments um even at
in 2028 the $15 an hour will be well
below the living what a living wage is
now and certainly will be in three years
so my third point is that I would
implore you to recognize that we have a
divided State and I'm not talking about
politically I'm talking about
economically we have we have fully 25%
of the households in New Hampshire earn
less than $50,000 a year and are
financially insecure and cannot um
maintain the can struggle to pay for
their daily bills um we pride ourselves
on having a strong economy and um and
for people to be independent but this is
my last point that I would ask you to
think about the other impact of minimum
wage is that um in some places companies
expect their pay their employees to make
up the differences that they need by
applying for public assistance and my
point is that if that public assistance
is coming at the at an expense to the
taxpayers so basically we are
subsidizing businesses and I feel
strongly the businesses should be able
to survive on their own and to pay
um their workers sufficiently well thank
you thank you ma'am I appreciate your
testimony subject
to representative lab's question I just
have one question thank you Mr chair
please ma'am you said uh at $15 and in
uh 2028 would still be far below the
living wage is that is that right yes I
okay is this really the right
Bill to solve that
problem
um I think raising the minimum wage
would certainly help it's not it's not
the full answer but at least it's a
start okay thank you at $15 an hour it's
twice what we get over twice what we're
paying now understood thank you okay
McKenzie so we've heard during the
course of the testimony that uh when you
ask somebody well who's actually paying
minimum wage in the
state um and the qu the question I have
uh is uh it does it come down to
employers uh who may stipulate that
nobody's paying 725 but they don't want
to pay 15 can you can you give any
insight into into what's behind that uh
in terms of whether they control Le the
market but they actually control the
wages they want to go up and down which
is what we heard I I know it's a
question to frame so if you can't answer
it fine um I'm sorry I'm not an
economist and so I really I'm a teacher
yes I don't have the answer to that
question I I guess I would say one thing
is that um you know there are always
arguments I I've also as as the one of
the representatives spoke I I've I've
run for office and I've spoken to a lot
of people and people are very concerned
about this but one I remember one person
and saying well if we raise the wages
then everything else will go up but um I
think I would agree with Mr trumble's
point that people who are not earning a
lot of money put all that money back
into the local
economy okay thank you so much ma'am for
your testimony we appreciate you coming
you and seeing no more pin cards and no
questions I will close the hearing on HB
and I'll will open the hearing on HP 744
relative to workers compensation
Indemnity benefits percentage
me
me and do we have cards on 744 I see
them coming up post haste and who's
going to introduce this bill is this
and if you could state your name and
position for the record then we'll go
ahead and get started thank you and I I
also have some hand handouts that might
uh good afternoon uh Mr chairman and for
the record my name is uh Mark McKenzie
and I am uh from District 40 in
Manchester
and uh serve the uh the float District
in in Manchester serving five ws in
Manchester I appear before you uh
introducing House Bill
744 and ask that you uh pass this bill
now let me uh this is a a little
complicated let me see if I can break
this down as best I
can but I sent out to you and I numbered
the pages and please if it's a little
messy uh I'm sorry about that but I
wanted to give you a sense of kind of
where the industry was and we started
through all of these reforms this
particular volume this book right here
uh is a 20y year about a 20 somewhat
year uh history of the uh workers
compensation changes
uh I don't think a whole lot of people
have this information I've shared it
with people but this gives you a sense
of what was what's been going on with uh
with unemploy with workers compensation
so back in the U in the
90s the system was in uh it was in a
crisis uh we had hollowed out most of
the uh people who were uh who were
willing to write insurance in New
Hampshire and we ended up uh with and if
you look at page 5 you can see at the
bottom of the paragraph uh there was a
proposed rate which was in the 33% range
um so th this and it ended up they
wouldn't accept that it ended up in the
12% rate but what what essentially
happened everybody was every all the
employee insurance companies left New
Hampshire with the exception of
one so there were a number of study
committees that occurred over the course
of the years um there was one that was
uh the Greg uh Governor Greg put
together uh uh there was one prior to
the Greg study there was one that Merill
put together there was one John Lynch
put together so there was a whole bunch
of studies that occurred over the course
of the
years now as a uh an advocate and I was
in the aflco for a number of years um I
worked on a number of those reforms over
the course of the years some of which I
absolutely did not agree with but we we
we did what we did um but what it has
resulted in is um is this is according
to judge uh the attorney was here last
week is that the market is much
different today the market is a good
line of business today and it wasn't
when we started through this process so
the question is um you know what
happened over the course of the years in
the market and what changed now I'm not
going to go through all these changes
because it would I'd be here three days
but I'm going focus in on one change
that occurred in the system that I think
we could uh we could deal with and we
could change and it would make a
difference to people uh and that is the
uh the change that occurred when they
reduced the amount that workers get from
66 and 23 to
60% and this occurred in uh in the 19
actually was in
1994 but they they took the rate down as
one of these ways to control costs and
they brought that down and it's been in
effect ever since now there's still a
few people that are under 66 and 2/3 but
for the most part new workers are under
60% and the question I have before this
committee is whether or not where the
market has recovered fairly well well we
have a pretty good line of business
where people are making money is it time
to start taking a look at some of the
cuts that were made over the course of
these years to bring this Market into
line so this is one of them and this has
been before this committee more than
once and the people behind me know that
but I think it's a good way it's a good
start it's a good start to bring this up
to where it was at one time and restore
this so the workers are making at least
66 and 2/3 of their pay so that's that's
essentially uh what the bill does now
there are questions that that have come
up with the labor department and some of
the lobbyists and I think we need to
work on this and one of the things is so
where do you draw the line uh in terms
of the of of this change if you think of
workers compensation as a system like a
train moving that people jump on the
train and they're going through the
system so it's hard to draw a hard line
to say this is going to be implemented
at this particular point so that's going
to be the challenge and I would ask that
we put a subcommittee together so we can
actually determine if if this is of
interest to the committee if they
support it where we how we implement
this thing uh it was not my uh intention
to go retroactively I'm to go back to
the beginning but I would want I would
want to start this and the there some
language the bill itself uh says one
we're going to startop this but I think
I think we need to really look at that
because it it's a legitimate thing as
the where we started now let me finally
say this
um this book here represents the changes
that took place uh if you think of
workers compensation if we don't we get
nothing else out of this testimony
workers compensation is a is a handshake
that took place a number of years ago
it's an agreement that employees would
not sue their employers they're
insulated they have insulated the
employers and in exchange for that there
was this system of work compensation
that was developed to make sure we take
care of workers now I got some I have
questions about about that and also I
have questions about some of the changes
that we made we probably should have
gone to court years ago as they made
these changes but that that be said here
we are here's the thing in front of you
here's what I think we can change and we
can do it and I think you're going to
hear a whole lot of people behind me
maybe
disagree but it's time to to kind of
restore some of these benefits thank you
Mr chairman okay so just to be clear
you're introducing this bill with the
intention
of interim no of what motion not OTP not
a it aop pass I'm sorry you want you
want to a to pass yeah but it's going to
need what is the subcommittee do then
what's we're going to have to work
through implementation actually when we
draw the line how and you'll hear some
of this from the do so how we you can't
just have a hard line because there but
there's a hard line in the Bill of
66.3 Right 3 no that's that's a
percentage but how you actually if you
think of people are in the process of
work as of of a claim so at what point
do you say okay they're the 66 and 2/3
group and that's that's kind of the
challenge for this and I think we have
people that are willing to work on that
to try to figure that out okay
representative alalani for a question
thank you Mr chairman um wouldn't the
first of the year be a great start is
January 1 of 26 well I I think you can
probably start it going forward but you
have a whole bunch of people that are
going to you know that are making 60%
and they're in the process now and they
settle on the other side of that so how
do you what what rate are they getting
you know so so would and that was raised
by the do and they'll explain it to you
and also some of the some of the
attorneys raised
that for a followup no good you good
okay good thank you
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question it
would seem to me that if the various
departments and uh could tell us how
many people are at
66 and then we would know kind of what
and what that dollar amount would look
like and what that would cost uh either
where it's whether it's going to come
from and that would be the one
complication then we if we agree that 66
and 2/3 is appropriate going forward
then then that's the only thing we have
to worry about is that correct well I
mean I think that the people uh to
answer your question representative the
people that administer the workers
compensation are here and they I think
they'll give you a sense of of of how
this is could work and whether or not
needs clarification and those kinds of
things so I I I think that that's what
we need to do and I think I've talked to
them enough to to understand that
something we probably need to make some
arrangements here some
changes okay representative K or
question representative flan and then
representative KK thank you Mr
chairman again uh going back to when
chairman infantine was here I seem to
remember his logic of the 60% and maybe
it's in your book that you have all of
the notes of the work as comp changes
but um the reason why it's 60% and not
66 and 3/4 is that we don't have any
sales income tax in the state of me in
New Hampshire whereas in Massachusetts
which has uh 66 and 3/4 does have an
income tax additionally is when you're
on on a workers comp out of work you
don't have all those anay expenses like
you know clothing gasoline uh food
outside of the home so that's why it's
not 100% of your wages that's why it's
60 and in this case is there a question
no are you familiar with that
conversation with the representative
inside you don't okay I I the only
recollection I have that uh uh
representative infant timee when I
talked to him he thought we had changed
this already it's been in front of this
labor committee a number of times I know
represent kale thank you Mr chair and
thank you again representative do you
recall our former colleague our late
colleague The Honorable herb Richardson
I do who tried to do this uh at least
going forward that he' had a terrible
injury working in a supermarket that and
I believe he was in danger of losing his
home because of there just wasn't enough
money coming in at 60% I think you did
lose his home actually but yeah I
remember that very well I remember him
and I I you know I uh I I think the
point of all this is is if the market is
doing really well is it time to start
thinking about you know giving some of
this back that was taken away away from
us during the course of the years and
this book is an example of it uh of all
the changes that have taken place and
many of them are not in the best
interest of working the workers in New
Hampshire and let me say one final thing
I'll sit down there's another thing
floating around and they Tred to do this
when I was on the commission with
Governor Lynch is is right now you're on
the hook for the medical benefits you
can the indemnity there's two sides of
work as comp it's the indemnity side and
there the medical side now right right
now you can't get relief from the iCal
side of of the of the the claim that's
with you now the indemnity side they can
settle and they do uh and that be the
that's the next thing I believe that
they're looking to do is to get out from
testimony and thank you for introducing
good afternoon uh chairman members of
the committee my name is Nathan fennessy
uh I'm an attorney at pretty flarity
here in conquer I represent the National
Council on Compensation Insurance also
known as
ncci uh for those of you some of you
probably already know uh but for those
of you that don't ncci is a licensed
advisory
organization uh that's authorized to
make rate filings on behalf of the
workers Compensation Insurance companies
in New Hampshire uh the filings are uh
objectively prepared B based off of
Actuarial uh methodology that's
generally recognized uh ncci doesn't
take a position on a bill like this uh
but one of the things we do is serve as
a resource to uh both the committee and
the insurance department and the labor
department so I'm here to testify
because I did get an inquiry uh
yesterday about whether or not NC CCI
had priced the potential impact of this
bill we have not priced it yet um I have
talked with uh the folks the actuaries
back in boa Ron uh and they could put
together a pricing probably for the week
of the 17th I don't know how that fits
with your schedule uh but that is
something that if the committee is
interested in doing uh we could
certainly do that for you
um I did uh just to respond on to I
think there was a question from
representative avalani regarding the so
there's two parts of the bill one is
changing the indemnity from 60% to 66
and 23 and then there's the question
about when that would take uh effect um
if as drafted it's 60 days after passage
I would anticipate that ncci would have
to do an interim filing uh because it
would potentially impact the rates that
were filed for 2025 which were based
upon the
60% uh number um the filing uh for
January 1 2025 was uh five and 5.6%
decrease um so it would have an impact
on that I I don't know what that number
would be um if the effective dat got
moved for example to like January 1 of
2026 that would just be part of the next
rate filing uh ncci does the rate filing
for the voluntary loss cost and also for
the uh
the residual market usually in August or
September and then the insurance
department will approve it uh with the
ex with the expected date that it would
take effect being January 1 of the
following year so if if the effective
date were moved to something like
January 1 of
2026 that would be part of the rate
filing process calculations for
2026 happy to take any questions you
have it go
ahead Rose
thank you Mr chairman um the I know the
ra isings use you all over in January um
the other question is if the the
representative Rose was if there are
people on the
program would they roll into the new
thing given that they're the the the
employers rates were set at 60% and if
they would be upgraded to the 66% come
the first or would it be just for new
claimants after the
first I I think that depends on how you
frame it my understanding would be if
you H usually the way the legislation
works is that it would apply to
prospective injuries so a past injury
that was under the 60% would still be
under that 60% Indemnity benefit that's
my understanding uh labor I think is
agree agreeing with me on that so I I
think that's the answer to that question
obviously you know you could amend it
however you choose followup for followup
sir and then a followup uh the payouts
we also mentioned that the payout would
that be under the 60% and under the
pre-existing policies for the employers
or would the would the carryover come
into the new policies and they would be
entitled to a higher payout under the um
not the indemnity part but on the payoff
part for an
injury uh if I understand your question
you're asking if the if the carrier
chooses to uh settle the indemnity
portion yes I would assume it would be
based upon on the existing 60% up until
effect clarification for clarification
so if the carried so get injured at 25
at the 60% and the say the payout was
25,000 but under the new thing is 66%
and the payout would be 30,000 just
follow along okay would they be eligible
for that 30,000 or would they still be
because they're injured in 25 would
still be only eligible for
25 I think it just depends on what the
effective date would be okay if if the
injury took place prior to the passage
of the bill I think they would still be
under the 60% is my understanding thank
you thank you Mr chairman Rose K thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question I'd be interested to know I
mean once we find out that the dollar
amount for the people who are at 60%
what that would cost I'd be interested
to know uh sort of the two the two
figures what it would be going forward
in January 26 to to have 66 going
forward and what it would cost for the
people uh who are at 60 to bring them
2026 would that be hard for you to
discern once we had the first part of
the big number so I think for purposes
of pricing what we' be looking at is
going forward what the what the impact
to the system would be um if the
question is sort of retroactively
figuring out uh the impact of changing
from 60 to 66 and two3 for existing
injuries uh I don't think that's
something that we would
be uh coming up with uh just because we
do it the work that ncci does is really
sort of going forward as far as what the
rate should be based upon the historical
Trends and losses whatnot so I don't
know if the the labor department or
someone else might be better served for
example because we don't know we won't
have all the information about someone
who may have already settled their
Indemnity
much representative Solomon and then
representative avalani Ju Just to be
clear when you talk about prospective
injury yeah I mean that's what I'm
thinking it's it it would be essentially
the date of the entry that's taking
place after this takes the effective
date correct thank you and if I can just
make one point of clarification so ncci
is dealing with what I'll call the
voluntary Market it's not picking up
self-insured it's not picking up any of
the municipalities who might be in
pulled risk uh program so it's a piece
of the pie it's probably a lot of the
pie but it wouldn't be the entire Pie as
far as what the impact would be to the
system okay represent alalani thank you
I was going to say ncci deals mostly
with private
employers most of your work is for
private private insurance
policies correct we we uh we would do
pricing related to private insurance
there are some public employers who
might have uh insurance through the
private Market I would say in New
Hampshire at least the vast majority do
not but there may be a few yep thank you
thank you Mr
chman all right sir thank you so much
you yeah if you could wait till the end
of the hearing please that that would be
hello my name is Christian cerella I'm a
chief Property and Casualty actuary at
the New Hampshire insurance department
I'm an associate of the casualty
Actuarial society and a member of the
American Academy of
actuaries the insurance department is
not taking a position on this bill
because it addresses a change to the
benefits awarded Injured Workers in New
Hampshire this is a policy matter and
will not change how we enforce the
insurance laws for the state of New
Hampshire I am here instead to speak
about anticipated consequences of the
bill as it may have a small but
noticeable effect on the Workers
Compensation Insurance Market in our
state as you know the Workers
Compensation Insurance system in America
rests on a balance between protecting
employees and their families from
debilitating workplace accidents and
permitting employers the Peace of Mind
in avoiding costly litigation as
representative McKenzie mentioned
earlier as is the case in every other
jurisdiction in the US benefits for
workers workplace injuries are governed
by state law when an employee misses
work due to an on the job injury they
are compensated a portion of their
average weekly wage New Hampshire
current New Hampshire law sets the wage
wage replacement at 60% of the workers's
average weekly wage this bill would
increase that benefit to 66 and 23%
increasing the wage replacement benefit
would necessitate an increase in what
workers what employers pay for workers
compensation insurance premiums to cover
increases to claims costs for insurance
Prov providers it is important to
understand that the proposed 11%
increase in Indemnity benefits would not
translate directly to an 11% increase in
premium it would cause a smaller
relative increase in premiums because
this is important wage replacement
accounts for a small portion of the
overall expenses borne by insurance
carriers in New Hampshire medical
expenses associated with a workplace
injury make up the majority of the loss
cost for
insurers also it is important to
acknowledge
that expenses associated with adjusting
a claim insurance carrier overhead taxes
licenses and fees commissions to their
agents and underwriting profit would not
be affected by this change further
decreasing the relative effect of this
change on premium in the end Indemnity
benefits for for injured workers make up
about a quarter of all
expenses all expenses considered in the
determination of workers compensation
insurance premium um
I would expect a change to the benefit
as proposed in this bill to result in a
in a small single digits um less than 5%
increase in overall premium for
employers at the same time it is
important to remember that loss costs
have decreased in New Hampshire for each
of the last 12 years and more than 60%
cumulatively over that period this means
the cost to insurance carriers for
workplace injuries relative to payroll
has dropped significantly with continued
improvements to workplace safety and
rapid and effective treatment in this
state for Injured Workers there is every
reason to expect the effect of an
increase in anticipated Indemnity costs
proposed in this bill to be mitigated by
continued decline in loss frequency and
medical expenses in other words if loss
costs continue to improve we may not see
the increase to premium anticipated from
this proposed change to benefits loss
costs are reviewed and adjusted annually
as Mr fennessy mentioned by the National
Council of insurance of compensation
insurers their loss costs for the next
calendar year are filed and reviewed and
approve and approved by our department
each summer and then become effective
January 1st and as Mr fennessy uh
concluded and I speculated there would
be there would need to be a a midyear
change in that if in fact the uh the
bill is is uh passed as as proposed and
that that would be a somewhat disruptive
to the market and for this reason um the
the insurance department does make one
suggestion for consideration by the
sponsor and this committee um if you
want to um mitigate that that effect on
the market we recommend changing the
effective date of this bill to January 1
2026 this would allow ncci to
incorporate the effect of the proposed
change to benefits on loss costs into
their annual rate submission and avoid
an out of cycle adjustment in the
current calendar year once again aside
from the the just mentioned suggestion
regarding the effective date of the
legislation the insurance department
does not take a position on this policy
questions and representative alalani
thank you Mr chairman um how many uh
workman's
comp insurance companies do we have in
the state right now um there are over a
hundred licens than writing insurance
insurance carriers in the voluntary
market and can you explain what the
volunt what a voluntary Market is and an
involuntary Market is so about in
calendar year 20 this is 2025 but I have
data from 2023 in 2023 there was about
280 or so million dollars worth of
written premium in the insurance Workers
Compensation Insurance market so that's
that private insurance Market that Mr
fennessy talked about doesn't include
self-insurance large hospitals
self-insure large businesses self-insure
it doesn't include pools like uh primex
U so for municipalities the state is
self-funded State Workers are covered
State these are for private employers
that need to purchase it in the in the
market so the voluntary Market are those
that's kind of that free exchange where
you call up an agent you ask for quotes
you get the quote like you do other
types of insurance whether it's property
Auto commercial Auto that kind of stuff
these are for businesses so of that of
that of that type of insurance there is
a small p pie of the the economy that
can't find a voluntary exchange and so
you know about 6% of that $280 million
about 6% of that does wind up in what we
call the residual Market the assigned
risk pool they you know there isn't a
carrier out there that is willing to
take on that risk for that that
workers's comp policy um the rates that
the premium that is paid by employers
that wind up in the assigned risk pool
are not substantially greater than what
they would get in the voluntary Market
it's just that any um you know any
losses any that that occur with that
business is then shared over the whole
workers compensation Market anybody
writing business so when we say the
voluntary Market we're talking about the
94% of the business that is done in the
in the private
Market my yes sir for a followup uh so
your 5% increase would basically be a W
by private businesses for this change
it's a very uh how should I say
it ballpark figure back of the envelope
I think you know when I looked at it it
was going to be around 2 to 4% that
would actually trickle all the way down
to premium and uh that would then be
translated over to premium that would
then be paid by employers yeah thank you
okay k Mr chair and thank you for taking
my question would you have an idea of
the average cost to Ure an employee I I
know there's different risks you know if
you have a roofer y or a secretary it's
probably a different rating but is there
an average number that employers pay to
comp I I average that would be difficult
I can say that there are minimum
premiums in in in our state so employers
are going to pay at least $800 to $1,000
and then depending on the type of
business they do the number of employes
emploees that they have it's all based
on payroll so you know however much
they're paying their employees will
affect that as you mentioned what their
employees are doing on a daily basis is
greatly going to affect that but you
know employers can pay as little as $600
a year and as much as tens and hundreds
of thousands of dollars a year represent
representative ly thank you Mr chair uh
just one question is it is it fair to
assume that with the fires the floods
the Hurricanes that insurance generally
speaking
is going to eventually Spike here I've
been told as a business owner to buckle
up on on liability and everything else
that's coming down the pike for the next
year and I guess my thought here is
everything needs to be taken to into
account here comp liability umbrellas
everything just want to get your
that workers compensation each of the
lines of business really runs
independently of each other so yeah yes
on to to your end are the fires out west
and the and and you know the Hurricanes
down south are they going to affect
property insurance business property
insurance
absolutely workers comp I would say no
because the different markets are priced
differently um and because workers
compensation Workers Compensation
Insurance is unique in the sense that
all benefits are are
statutorily you know decreed
ncci when they're developing their rates
you know perspectively they can look
back to see you know how much it costs
to return carry return workers to to
their jobs to return employees to their
to their to their jobs and it's not that
is not going to be affected by fires
it's not going to be affected by
hurricanes yeah we follow thank you Mr
Chair say all state has a workman's comp
division but they also have a home
owners division are they not related at
some point down the road do you
understand what I'm trying to say I I I
hear what you're saying
and generally speaking that's not the
way Insurance Works um they will most
insurance carriers will will price their
various types of business separately um
because the risks are very very
different and that I would not consider
that to be gener you know doing as you
say and and kind of merging the business
and saying hey we need a little bit here
we need a little bit there to cover that
is not kind of accepted Actuarial
practice yeah
yeah
avalani thank you Mr chairman do you
have the history on why we pay the 60%
instead of the 66 and
2/3 I I do not I started working at the
state about 10 years ago and it's been
60% the whole time that I've been
here okay I will say it is unique
Nationwide that we're the only state we
that percent is lowest in New Hampshire
lower than every other state in the
nation thank you okay represent
K and thank you once again so the the
impacts the way to the way to keep cost
low for workers comp is fewer claims and
less expensive claims is that
correct right sort of you're talking
about the individual employer yeah right
so the the the history of the individual
empy employer and kind of their loss
experience greatly affects what they're
paying the next year yes thank
you all right so seeing no further
questions I would like to call uh Miss
Albert please from labor thank you sir I
testimony good afternoon thank you very
much my name is Danielle Albert the
Deputy Commissioner of the New Hampshire
Department of Labor I'm here today with
um Attorney John garan he is the
Department's general counsel um the
department is neutral on the bill we
have reviewed the language we do believe
we understand its stated intent and
purpose we believe that we can
administer it um relative to the
proposed language itself um the
department would highlight um one or two
technical points um and I'm going to go
as slowly as possible tell me to slow
down if you need me to um the the
language in the bill is amending what is
currently
60% um a compensation rate to Injured
Workers that's based on 60% of that
Injured Workers average weekly wage
that's the current calculation um I
think it's important to frame Indemnity
payment um in the types that it that it
can be paid in individuals who are out
of work as the result of a work injury
can be totally disabled or partially
disabled in the statute there are
actually four sections that address
payment of total disability
and partial disability um section 28 and
section 28a address temporary total
disability and permanent total
disability um as written the bill is
currently only amending one of the total
sections it's section 28 um so a
suggestion would be and we've discussed
this with representative McKenzie um to
con keep consistent if this change were
to go through you um you could amend the
language or it may be beneficial to
amend the language in 28 1 a 28a so that
the 66 and 2/3 is applicable uh across
both temporary total disability and
permanent total disability and just for
context the mathematical calculation for
how you reach the compensation rate
across uh temporary versus permanent is
exactly the same it's simply a medical
status that demarcates whether you're
temporarily disabled or to uh uh uh
permanently disabled and we have the
same technical suggestion um for the uh
for the amendment to 281a 31 uh 31- a
that is changing the uh percentage to 66
and 23 but only for permanent partial
disability it's not addressing section
281 a31 which addresses temporary
partial disability um so to keep it
consistent if that's the idea and intent
there's um an ie could be given towards
uh changing those sections as well to
reflect the 6 6 and
2/3 um and again just like with uh the
the total disability benefits the
difference between permanent and
temporary for partial disability
benefits is simply a medical status a
doctor has placed an injured worker at
maximum medical improvement and
determined they're at a certain type of
medical end point um in general just by
way of benefits Administration what
would the 66 and 23% change be doing
practically um it's going to change the
weekly compensation rate the way that
it's calculated for the eligible
individuals receiving it um that will
also have impact on the way that
permanent impairment awards are paid
permanent impairment Awards when an
injured worker is eligible for one are
based off of a prescribed number of
weeks as set by Statute for the injured
body part based off the individual's
compensation rate so if there's a change
to the way that you calculate
compensation rate for a particular
injured worker that will translate over
to um payment of permanency Awards as
well it will also have impact on Cola
adjustments the cost of living
adjustments under Section 29 which
incorporate the mathematical percentages
from section 28 when uh injured worker
is eligible for Cola adjustments so
those are the benefits that the change
would be affecting within the system um
the department understands um had heard
from representative McKenzie and from a
few others there's some questioner about
when uh the effective date and who would
be impacted or how would this impact
existing claims um on review of the
proposed language the Department's
understanding is this would be a
prospective application and the
prospective application would more
likely than not track to date of
injuries that occur on or after the
effective date um and that's in general
uh consistent with how the workers
compensation system and benefits work
and because your average weekly wage and
compensation rate really are established
at the time that it's determined you
have a compensable injury um uh just to
kind of address the sort of voluntary
insurance market and the self-insured
Insurance Market uh whether you are
looking at a self-insured employer who's
pooling their money or participating as
part of a trust or whether or not you're
looking at an employer who elects to
purchase voluntary coverage an injured
worker is an injured worker so were this
change to go into effect uh when a
compensation rate is calculated for an
injured worker it would be using this
formula um as put forward in the
proposed language regardless of whether
or not the insurance carrier is a
voluntary Market carrier or a
self-insured carrier um and I am happy
to answer any questions um should the
any represent Sullivan thank
um that uh um effective date in the
prospective nature um based on the date
of injury um is that something that
needs to be written into the uh the the
bill and the statute or is it something
that the department would deal with
through
rulemaking I don't I mean I think if the
if there's an intent or or thought from
the committee that Clarity needs to be
added to the statute it certainly could
be added to the statute um if it were
something that ultimately ended up
needing to be addressed by rule the
department could look at that and and do
it um in you know to to be clear as to
why we don't view it as retroactive I we
believe that in order for it to be a
retroactive application language to that
effect would actually need need to be
put into the statute thank
you okay uh representative hall and then
representative
amalani uh am I correct in understanding
that this increase is completely funded
by premiums there's no effect
on uh any other there doesn't the money
doesn't need to be drawn from any other
source um if I understand the question
uh correctly and correct me if I don't
absent the money would be coming from or
paid through the insurance carriers so
if the question is whether or not it
would draw from any sort of state fund
correct okay thank you um you know that
the state is a self-insured you know
entity so and we are the state is a um
self-insurers itself um so there could
be some impact there um I'm not the most
well-versed in in sort of the rates and
or how um that aspect would work but um
you know if the state were to look at
claims and determine that some
additional monies were needed their
potentially could be um some impact but
by and large for any in uh insurance
policy that's voluntary that's being
borne through the voluntary Market not
drawing off of any sort of State um or
public fund that I'm aware of
Representative
avalani thank you Mr chairman thank you
Deputy Commissioner um for the payments
at 66 and2 should we also look at the
duration because it says 262 weeks
should should there be a change in the
duration of benefits if we are
increasing them and the front end we
should we decreasing them in the back to
mitigate the overall effect of using
general funds for self-insured or having
an in increase in policies for private
insurers
or you know where I'm going sure yeah no
it's an excellent question um I think
I'll just sort of note um to be hyper
technical about it the 26 62 we uh cap
is only applicable to partial benefits
so total disability benefits whether
they're temporary total disability
benefits or permanent totally total
disability benefits uh can arguably go
on for a person's lifetime uh and there
are certainly claims where an individual
has received total disability throughout
the entirety of their life from their
date of injury going forward if an
injured worker goes on to or goes into a
partial disability status typically
marked by that individual returning to
work they have some earnings but not uh
equaling the earnings that they had at
the time of their injury there's a
partial benefit that the insurance
carrier pays um that's determined by
paying this would propose 66 and 23% of
the difference between the average
weekly wage at the time of injury and
the average earnings following the
partial return to work um if the
individual is on partial disability
benefits at at the time that they hit
their
262nd week of payment by operation of
law they time out and the insurance
carrier can cease making those payments
the question as to whether or not
there's sense or it's appropriate uh to
alter that time frame I would defer to
the committee I think that would be more
of a a policy determination um certainly
if there was an eye or intent towards
changing that the department would be
able to administer um whatever that
change would
be thank you
okay repr Clair thank you Mr chair thank
you Deputy Commissioner how long does a
person have to be out to be able toay
start claiming or or collecting on the
benefit yeah that's an excellent
question um when an injured worker goes
out of work the statute I want to say
it's section 22 sets a grace period so
the first 3 days the insurance carrier
is not liable to make payment to them
unless the period of disability extends
for 14 days or longer if the injured
worker reaches that um 14th 15th day uh
they haven't received payment yet and
comp benefits are supposed to be paid on
a weekly Bay uh basis so when they hit
that 14th or more days uh that they're
out of work or or disabled from work the
insurance carrier should be going back
and retroactively paying those first
three days the injured worker goes back
to work let's say on day five or six
they're only going to get paid for no
have to do
math the the two days or three days that
they were out because that grace period
is going to apply for the first three
days it's slightly modified for
individuals who go back to work on a
temporary alternative Duty status I
believe the grace period for those
individuals five days you're welcome
great thank you represent K thank you Mr
chair and thank you Deputy so uh if we
were to uh add these sections that you
recommended to be consistent and move
the date out to uh January 1 2026 and
only look at this
perspectively uh this would be fairly
simple to understand the cost and we've
heard from ncci that they would be
figuring that out and we heard from the
actuary that would be one to five not
necessarily five but there were already
reductions because we've been so safe
and so good uh would this be a fairly
easy lift uh thinking that uh we would
have better protections and and that the
medical claims the duration is based on
the medical condition not what we say it
should
be I'll I'll speak you know relative to
whether or not it's an easy lift I'll
speak from the Department's perspective
I don't want to speak for ncci or the
department of insurance I think um I'll
leave it to them to to determine what's
feasible or not feasible for them um you
know if this were to go into effect in
January of 2026 uh the department would
be able to track to that date and and as
as um claims reports are coming in for
the Department to oversee and or
regulate we would be able to keep track
of that um again our understanding of
the language as drafted is that it's
going to be a prospective application uh
if the date is 60 days from the date of
Passage if it's a more defined date
whatever that may be we would be looking
to that date and injuries that occur
more likely than not occur on or after
that date to determine um you know
whether or not when an insurance carrier
is reporting I've started paying
Indemnity benefits to an individual and
there is a specific filing that they
have to provide to the department they
have to provide what's called a memo of
payment uh and they have to provide a
wage record showing earnings so that the
department can vet and verify that they
are using um have calculated the average
weekly wage correctly and then computed
the compensation rate which is what this
bill is addressing um accurately we
would be checking for injuries on or
after whatever the effective date is did
you use the appropriate percentage in
determining the compensation rate uh the
department I mean would need some time
to update we provide a variety of
resources and tools for insurance
carriers to use in order to perform
these mathematical exercises we provide
trainings to insurance carriers to
assist them in accurately um doing these
calculations and filing the required
documents with the Department we would
need some time I think to update those
tools to assist um to assist insurance
carriers and employers with the change
um but I I don't believe it would be an
honorous lift for us to do that thank
followup please thank you uh and again
since the other uh 49 states already
have this uh 66 and 2/3 the carriers it
would not be a shock to them they would
not be all new what do I do now uh in
that situation correct
that's a good question I I don't know
that I can speak for the insurance
carriers I think certainly if they're in
hopefully if they're informed of the
change they're aware of what the
calculation is they should be able to
make an adjustment um I don't know that
the Department's in a position to speak
for whether or not it will be difficult
or not for them thank you you're welcome
okay represent nalani please thank you
Mr chairman I'll ask you ask the uh
Deputy Commissioner the same question I
asked the man from the insurance
department uh do you know why we are at
the
60% yeah I my answer I think is going to
Echo um Mr citarella's the change went
into effect my recollection is sometime
in the 90s um it was well before my time
at the department I mean I have spent a
fair amount of time um both out of
interest and related to my work with the
Department looking through legislative
history um I wasn't present for any of
those clearly any of those meetings or
conversations um so I understand the
basis of the change as it's been
explained to me by other you know by
other Representatives or from my
engagement um throughout um being at the
legislature and from reading the
legislative history but do I have direct
knowledge of that I do not thank
you okay seeing no further comments and
having no further pin cards uh thank you
so much you're welcome um before we
adjourn on 744 though I just I want to
ask the
considered opinion of the committee so
the NCI ncci report would provide a more
detailed analysis of the financial
impact of this is that Mr Fantasy could
you come on up
please uh is it your opinion that it
would be worth waiting for that analysis
and and including that in
testimony I hear one yes yes in
general okay
uh is it possible for you to produce
something um with the modifications as
as addressed by the
17th So when you say the modifications
as addressed so we should assume that
the effective date would be January 1
2026 correct okay and then the other
thing and and I would like if uh
representative McKenzie your thoughts on
self-insured as part of it rather than
voluntary are there any thoughts from
the committee on
that oh that's possible too
representative alalani thank you thank
you Mr chairman um so the four sections
of the um workman's comp block for the
temporary p temporary disability po so
we missed two so could you do the four
sure on that the um effective date on
126 um I think we heard from the
insurance department that the
self-insured really do essentially be
adjusting that that that doesn't really
fall within your purview it does not
yeah we we they just don't report the
claims data to us so we don't have the
information to be able to do that sort
of calculation okay but that represent
that represents 4% of the popul or 6% of
the population uh no the 6% that was
referred to I think was the residual
Market which uh okay it is something we
would be able to price okay great so
what what I would propose and just a
just a sensing of the of the committee
is that we recess this bill we reconvene
on the
18th with an amendment as we just
discussed and an analysis from
ncci so that we can get a better
understanding of aact with the impact is
that
generally everyone up with that okay
more okay please thank you again Mr
chairman um could the insurance
department come up with a I don't say
public sector but the public
sector what it might raise the cost of
the general fund if the state was to do
it um I know primix really doesn't
answer to ncci that they would answer to
you um could you could J all them to get
numbers that would be difficult because
we don't regulate primx we don't
regulate the
self-insurance we regulate the voluntary
market and and the residual market and
so they don't we don't have any
authority over them did you ask them for
what what this might cost them if we
made this change they would might be
interested
in that down the road is that something
that you would be able to do or would it
Department of Labor representive Albert
I didn't want to look over there but
they do the hand from the back of the
you thank you U the Department of Labor
is the agency that regulates
self-insured entities um you know
relative to how their their rates are
set or what they charge in premiums
that's not within our jurisdiction per
se um but I'm happy to try to reach out
to administrative Services risk manager
M who is the um that's the sector of the
state agency that um kind of handles
state workers the state's workers
compensation claims um to see if they
can be of assistance follow for Fallout
um I know as would would be helpful in
that um at the state level but how do we
get down to the county and local level
if there's going to be increase I hate
to say it because primx I think is the
only game in town how would we get at
least numbers from them to say okay well
this might increase 10% at the local
level 5% at the county and then the
state might have a 3% increase it it's
an excellent question um I'm I'm not
sure to be honest uh I don't know I
don't know the way or if that data can
be captured it's not one of the
requirements in order to be self-insured
neither the statute the regulations um
require that the self-insured entities
provide uh provide that information to
the department and it's not a piece of
information that's contingent upon their
being certified to self-insure um I can
try to take a look it's but I do want to
be clear it's not information that the
Department of Labor has so I'm not
really certain where where it could or
would come from and for a followup um
but um primex if there's any injuries at
the local County or state level they
would have to report to the Department
of Labor that is correct so if primex is
the um third party administrator for the
host of towns municipalities school
districts whomever is within their um
their group or their pool the injuries
would be reported to the department but
I believe and tell me if I'm not
understanding the question correctly
believe you're asking after what would
that do to sort of their premium rates
or what they're charging um or the c or
are you looking for more of the cost of
the claims Administration no no just the
cost if there's going to be increase at
the local level for their insurance
policies because they have to pick up
this extra 11% increase um we've heard
from ncci the insurance there might be a
small increase if that going to
translate down to uh the state
self-insured so that just might be more
General funds or if it just if it's
Prime X it might be a small increase in
their premiums to their municipality I I
will see if it's something that we may
be able to put together I'm I'm not
certain that we have the data I would
have to go back to the department and
check but I'm happy to see thank you
thank appreciate that thank you good
question okay so that's the course of
action then if you folks could come back
on the 18th and uh we'll we'll uh pick
up this testimony again with more
current data thank you so much and uh I
744 the on 540 on 542 yeah no I I think
let's let's hold off on that
representative uh rather than try to
stick it in the next four minutes
be Adam
McKenzie can you come can you come here
please for one a
minute
e
all right I'm opening the session on
House Bill 7 uh question
FN and representative kahill I have your
card and if you could introduce the bill
please thank you very much Mr chair uh
my name is Michael Cahill I represent
the wonderful towns of new fields and
New Market in Rockingham
10 and we're here to talk about 378 FN
and I think we can nearly we might be
able to lose the FN with with the
amendment
which I is always a good thing to do
I've made several adjustments to you
know please this one and that one uh but
basically what I've what I'm trying to
do is make sure
that
oh uh make sure that the in the event of
a situation uh beyond the control of an
employee uh who
has uh unused vacation time and is
denied the opportunity to to take that
vacation time that under certain
situations limited situations they would
be
paid uh the other situation that's
covered in in the event that the
business is sold uh It's Not Unusual and
I'd say it's rather typical that the if
the employee stays on with the new owner
they normally carry over you know the
the unused time and that's part of the
sale agreement so that's another option
in that
situation uh the sale of the business
and the person just walks away and
doesn't pay because their policy said
upon termination uh we don't pay
vacation I I think that's a
problem so I have
included let's see you had the
bill you have a couple of examples uh of
wage
claims that uh where the claim it did
not Prevail largely because of this uh
policy blanket policy and uh I'll just
take a look at this most recent one uh a
gentleman was a a car salesman and I
know we don't necessarily hold Carl
salesman in in high esteem but he went
he worked and he worked for I think 13
years for the for the company and then
they closed the
dealership and their policy was we don't
pay at the at termination he was not
fired for cause he didn't uh wasn't any
uh any issue like that I I happen to
Google his name and I saw these nice
reviews customers that Au thought he did
a swell job it's just that that was
their policy the other thing I want to
draw your attention to is that they had
this
the
um right no used time will be paid out
at the end of employment whether the
termination of employment is voluntary
or involuntary and whether the unused
time is personal sick or or vacation uh
this person's acred PTO 3 weeks would
have was worth uh $
so it's not small
change
um he he made the mistake of not
bringing documentation and this is part
of what I I I hope the department when
someone files a claim they say you know
this is the sort of thing you need to
bring with you and you're going to make
your best effort if you're not going to
bring a lawyer you should know exactly
what evidence you need to bring and um
his defense was kind of un his claim was
kind of unusual that he felt the policy
uh because the the handbook had said
this is not a legal agreement or
contract that you know and yet you know
he signs the policy every year here so
that that that was not effective and
um in any case uh he Li he's out 5,700
and change uh in my own Community uh an
assisted living center uh the business
was sold the they had the similar policy
it's not paid out of vacation and five
people who stayed on with the new
employer filed wage
claims and they lost uh a total of 20
261 and44 so roughly in the range of 300
to just under $600 each and we're
talking someone working in an assisted
living center back in 2014 probably not
making a lot of money and and this was
uh someone I happen to know
uh she was a shipper worked at a
computer reseller company and they had a
very nice policy uh they the the owner
included some notes Here in his defense
um so the V vacation requests have to be
in writing at least two weeks in
um vacation cannot be carried over to
the following year however vacation pay
is granted said at the beginning of the
following calendar year in L of taking
the actual time off uh no more than 10
days of vacation can be taken at one
time without special management
approval
and uh one day she goes to work and
she's and she's laid off so there was no
opportunity to take two oh two weeks
from now I'd like to take this time off
that just wasn't possible so there's
there's a situation where you know she
had she was out
uh
um
23508 and no fault of her own uh a good
employee who just happened to get laid
off without knowing that she really
should have been taking all the vacation
time you know take a day off every week
just in case they lay you off is that
the way we want to work in New Hampshire
is that that is that what employeers
want to do I I don't think so that's not
what the employers here telling me that
they would
do
um so uh you all have this document
which sort of a bit of a
history um and we go back to the
Department's records of of these events
it's not uh it's bad it's bad if it
happens to to you but it's bad if it
happens to someone else and and so in 20
in
2018 um there were wage claims there
were 121 wage claim hearing
and I I want to add that not every wage
claim goes to a hearing sometimes you
know they they just settle it or they
don't follow through uh but 121 wage
claims were posted on the on their
website which they don't do anymore and
again they they weren't posting every
single one but of that 121 29 which is
24% involved vacation PTO wages and the
next year and 34 of them uh were posted
and 9 which is 26% involveed vacation
wages in
2021 uh 51 wage claims uh 15 of these
that's
29% 2022 35 wage claims of those only
three but that's 8% and if you're in the
8% it's important to you um in 2020 the
the wage claims were not posted and but
there were four 144 that invol and that
had PTO as an issue uh of those 61 which
is 42% ultimately went to a
hearing uh parties may have reached an
agreement or
settled
um let's see and and more recently
20124 there were 188 wage claim hearings
of those eight or 4% involved vacation
PTO so it it happens frequently enough
so that we should do something about it
and if it happens to one of your
constituents or one of your family
members uh you might say that that's not
right that wasn't fair and why would why
should the employer not pay what the
employee had earned that's the whole
premise here that the vacation is
earned and when something happens that
circumstances that are like and limited
as they are in this bill uh it's I think
it's the obligation of the employer to
in the in the case of the of the uh
ownership changing and the employees
staying on and make arrangements you
know that's going to be reflected in the
purchase rights but that's your job make
arrangements so that those those
vacation hours are transferred or pay
them um the other thing that I want to
mention I know we're we're terribly
interested in protecting the UN
Insurance uh the insurance trust fund
and when you lose your job you can go
down to the unemployment office and they
ask you did you get sever or vacation
pay and if the answer is yes they want
to know how much and you won't claim you
won't have a claim any unemployment
benefits until that amount is exhausted
so we are we are in some sense uh
protecting that fund easing the burden
on our employers if we pass this bill
now let me get to the
amendment so
um right so we we do add in here not
terminated for clause which I I thought
should have been fairly obvious but we
had it just to make sure we added the 30
the maximum of 30 days of unused time
payoff that's something that the UNH
system has a very generous uh
plan uh we exclude sick days because we
hope you don't get sick but if you if
you were sick you should have taken the
time um and we talk about we talked
about PR rating this in the past and I
know representative bani came to
understand what that means so it it's
really just a fer system if you don't
have the
acral and the only other odd thing in
here uh is is uh apart from last year's
Bill where we had people who have
seasonal
employees uh construction or uh
landscaping and they have an there's a
time when the weather changes and
there's a layoff and I know from Mr
labers that uh if it's going to be 11
weeks and the employ writes a note the
employee can collect unemployment and
not do a not do a job search because
they're going back to work I I didn't
put that in here because I don't know if
the season will be 11 weeks or 12 weeks
or if there could be an extension but if
there's if they have no reasonable
Assurance of coming back to work if they
say no I'm not going to bring it back
you know when the weather is permitting
then you should get your vacation pay um
paid to you
and go collect unemployment anyway but
you should get the vacation pay and that
will reduce the unemployment or delay
the claim so those are the the odd
wrinkles that we have because you can't
have one size fits all there's lots of
what about what about what if but this
is basically uh not we the there's a lot
of businesses in New Hampshire that have
a license a license to do this or to do
that but there's no license to
steal and this is wage theft although
it's legal right now and I hope you will
support the amendment and the and the
bill as
amended okay thank you and if we can
hold on questions right now I want to
call Mr carrian because he's got to
leave here uh MOS go and so uh represent
K if you could just stand by for a
second thank
you not that you were going anywhere
anyway sorry this was sched so late in
the day Mr that's all right thank you so
much uh John garan uh general counsel
for the Department of Labor and thank
you so much for uh accommodating my uh
schedule and child care needs uh the
department is neutral on this bill
though the department has um worked
extensively with um representative
kahill on prior versions of this bill uh
we do have one piece of technical
guidance or technical suggestion which
is um in the original Bill line
19 um uses this phrase reasonable
Assurance or no reasonable assurance
um of the employee being able to return
to the employer uh it's not clear to the
department what evidence would be needed
to show a reasonable Assurance for
instance whether it's got to be in
writing whether it doesn't have to be in
writing um or what really qualifies as
reasonable so our suggestion would be to
um clarify or or make more specific what
would be reasonable um both for so that
we have clear guidance when it comes to
enforcement um but also setting clear
expectations for employers uh and their
own practices beyond that I'm happy to
take questions uh that's great input any
questions or
comments representative avalani thank
you uh that was going to be a question
and on the amendment uh do you have that
in front of you I do yes um can you
define
cause what was definition if you were
looking at it what would be defined as
yeah under line seven fourth word over
sure um the bill does not independently
seem to Define that I mean the the
department does not have an independent
definition of termination for cause um
perhaps there's a definition in the
employment security laws but there
there's none under our laws so we would
um if if the committee wish to Define
that as well that would be that would be
great thank you thank you Mr
all right good point any other
questions all right sir I think we made
our uh cut off at
415 you won't be in trouble when you get
home thank you thank you and represent
kill could you come on back up thank you
thank you sir yeah um and do we have any
questions from can I can I help with Mr
avani's Question As You Wish thank you
sir um yes this is the cause is not
defined and this is part of why it's a
problem to have it but we it's like
obscenity you you you can't Define it
but you know it when you see it so uh
and the Department of Employment
Security when this when someone is fired
for cause they'll ask them what happened
and they can appeal if if it's a
reasonable person if a reasonable person
would find this situation untenable you
know you if you quit you quit that I
know they have that that consideration I
believe it may also apply for unjust
firing and there may be some there may
be some mechanism either in the
Department of Labor or in Employment
Security that says you w Really fire it
unjustly and uh something else has to
happen I will be happy to ask Mr lers
and I know we'll have an answer but this
this is this is a thing and and
certainly people are fired and they're
giving the reason and I know people have
to be very careful uh that they that
they dot their eyes and cross their tees
when when they terminate someone uh
generally speaking but I think when it
does happen and if is if is determined
to be um reasonable and that the the
just cause then that person would not
qualify to receive their unused vacation
time and they probably would not qualify
for unemployment so I think labors would
be the guy to talk to um I'd be happy to
add written into the piece about the uh
assurance
representative
solivan in in the world of Labor uh law
um it's common contract language under
disciplinary Clauses to say someone will
not be fired or disciplined without just
cause and just cause has a very uh uh
it's very well defined in in labor law
um I'm not suggesting you add the word
just but I think it's the same spirit
that essentially you have to have
an explanation as to what this person
did to cause you to fire
them um yes and I believe that uh you
have to have uh I think it might be
called a pip or something where you tell
someone you warn someone this is what I
don't like and if you do it again you
know whatever it's twice or three times
you're out
uh uh I haven't been
fired so all right any other questions
represent labr thank you Mr chair thank
you sir for taking my question how did
we arrive at the 15 employee number just
out of curiosity how do we get there
rather than say a um a gross sales of a
company um that was provided to me by
former Deputy Commissioner Ogden and he
said it was not not an unfamiliar number
to to small businesses that's a
threshold for something else which I
don't recall exactly what that was but
it's it's another it's we didn't want to
give him a new number so it's a number
that's already there perhaps Mr avalani
is uh could pull this out of his
pocket
okay okay I have a declination on that
request um all right sir thank you so
much thank
you and if we can
thank you uh my name is Alison miloto
I'm the co-owner and founder of Blue
Lion we're in New Hampshire BAS based HR
Consulting company um and I provided you
a copy of my testimony which I'll read
now uh dear Representatives thank you
for your time today my name is Alison
milotto I'm a co-founder of Blue Lion an
HR Consulting firm based out of New
Hampshire a little repetitive there uh
we have served hundreds of businesses
and nonprofits here in the granite state
on matters related to HR including paid
time off policy creation Administration
as well as terminations layoffs mergers
and Acquisitions our team of over 14 HR
professionals has a breath of knowledge
across many Industries as well as
employers uh size and makeup I'm
testifying to express my opposition of
House Bill 378 as it currently stands
despite the commendable efforts to
address several concerns raised in Prior
years while the inclusion of the RSA to
clarify due wages when the due wages are
owed the removal of sick time from the
payout and the consideration of
resignation scenarios are improvements
significant issues still remain
unaddressed that weren't further
attention first I strongly oppose the
provision requiring employers to pay out
unused time for employees that are
terminated for perform performance I
understand the bill has been modified to
eliminate those terminated for cause
however that is often viewed differently
than those that are uh terminated for
performance issues for cause usually
implies misconduct gross negligence or
theft we would recommend and support a
change to include all involuntary
terminations except those Illustrated in
the bill um which are the sale of the
company or a position
elimination also known as a
layoff in addition this legislation if
unchanged to include termination for
performance would place an undue
hardship on many of the nonprofit
organizations nonprofits often provide
richer time off policies as a means to
attract and retain talent in lie of
offering higher salaries if this bill
were to pass these organizations would
be forced to reassess their generous
policies as the financial strain of
paying out in the um very benefits that
help these organizations compete for
talent and ultimately harming
employees third the bill does not
adequately address the growing
prevalence of unlimited or flexible time
off policies many companies have adopted
these policies which allow employees to
take as much time off as they need
within reason without the need to acrew
or deduct from a time off Bank however
this bill provides no guidance on how
unused time would be calculated or
compensated under such Arrangements when
I testified on this matter previously
this was a key point of confusion and
concern and it remains unresolved to
address these issues I recommend the
following adjustments to the legislation
exclude employees terminated for
performance as opposed to reduction in
force clear guidelines already exist to
distinguish between these scenarios and
such an exclusion would ensure that
failure to perform is not rewarded
exclude nonprofit organizations from
these Provisions or create an
alternative standard for them to protect
their ability to offer competitive
competitive benefits without
jeopardizing their financial stability
and third provide specific guidelines
for handling unlimited or flexible time
off policies ensuring Clarity and
fairness for both the employers and the
employee thank you for considering these
points while I support the effort to
enhance workplace protection it is
essential that we avoid creating undue
burdens on employers and nonp nonprofits
or inadvertently rewarding misconduct I
urge you to make the necessary
adjustments to ensure this legislation
is fair practical and considerate of all
stakeholders I also invite anyone
working on legislation such as this to
reach out and discuss how it may impact
employers here in the granite state with
one email or phone call you could have
access to um how it may impact hundreds
thank you for your time I can take your
that's very clear and concise testimony
thank you are there any questions
represent McKenzie
thank you for your testimony appreciate
it what I'm trying to square
is is if I had a a 401k or I had a
savings account health savings account
and I was terminated with cause MH would
you lose that
no so followup yes please so then if I
have banked certain
time and had I not been terminated that
time would have been mine so so is it
the does the logic follow that that's
not their time they have not accumulated
that time yeah I can understand how your
logic is going um I guess part of the
other confusion is if I have a
front-loaded time off policy then you're
getting paid out on stuff that maybe you
haven't quite earned yet but also the
benefit that I'm providing you is time
away from work the benefit I'm giving
you is not the ability to have a free
paycheck it's the ability to take time
off of work and unfortunately due to
your lack of performance you have a lot
of time off from work now so I would
argue that the benefit is the ability to
take a paid day to not come to work it's
not the dollar figure that we're
associating to those hours for a
followup thank you uh I wasn't great in
accounting um but let me say but let me
ask you this you have a nonprofit
who uh should be calculating in their uh
liabilities the cost of uh the the
accumulated vacation time and all those
kinds of things corre so if they if they
decide to cut
that um cut somebody off um it would it
be to their advantage and would that be
an incentive in some some ways uh to
limit their liability and their exposure
for what may be uh
their inability to properly track that
you so I think what your question is am
I going to save money because I'm going
to fire you and not pay you out
essentially well it was there's a
costant did they are they doing proper
Accounting in yes so my argument would
be and most nonprofits do have the
ability to pay their their staff salary
so if I have budgeted in my budget for
my executive assistant at my nonprofit
for $50,000 for the year that 50 ,000
that I've budgeted includes two weeks
vacation because while she's not working
in that position for those two weeks I'm
paying her but it's included in that
annual amount now if halfway through the
year she terms I didn't pay she didn't
take her vacation and I had to pay it
out but then I'm fortunate enough in
this market that I replaced her so as
soon as she left I hired someone new my
we'll use 52,000 because it's easy my
annual cost now just went up to 54,000
because the new person's going to have
the two weeks as well so it is an
accounting problem um and I do think to
your point um would someone fire someone
so that they didn't have to pay time out
I the employment Market is still at the
employees Advantage um it is still hard
to find good work good help um so I
don't think that people are just firing
employees so they don't have to pay out
what's
that okay thank you um any further
questions representative avalani thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for your
testimony um it was
um um I have a would you believe
question that I believe everything
you've just said that employees should
only have to pay for 52 weeks of work
and not pay out
you wi it would be you believe but
poorly executed just for the record any
other questions
I could just add one more statement
about the the 15 employee question from
earlier um the other legislation in New
Hampshire that follows that is your
safety manual so at the point of having
50 employ 15 15 15 employees you also
have to have a safety program and a
safety manual so it is already as uh
representative kahill mentioned in the
HR world it's already a Mark that we're
familiar with so they're not adding in
another number that you have to remember
oh when I hit this this happens so 15 is
already a number a good input thank you
all right ma'am thank you so much I
appreciate it thank you thank you for
your
Banky
bery thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee for the year record my
name is Bruce berky I'm with Shin
Capital group here in conquered and we
represent uh many different business
groups and individual businesses
throughout the state of New Hampshire
among them are the lodging and
Restaurant Association of New Hampshire
ski New Hampshire um the electrical
contractors and U next era Seabrook
station and New England convenience
stores and I want to
um well I'm going to applaud the HR
representative who gave excellent
testimony
and I want to say that the Crux of her
testimony is
that she is asking this committee not to
let the state of New Hampshire get
between the employer and the
employee that's the bottom line of this
bill it's a mandate it's a
requirement and under law today first
it's been long held public policy that
government not mandate to employers what
their employee benefits must include but
only that the employer give adequate
notice of what those benefits
are the current law already requires
employers to provide written
descriptions to employees of what
employee benefits will
be 378 does not account for employers
with use with use it or lose it paid
vacation benefits it does not account
for employers that provide paid personal
time off but do not distinguish between
sick days personal time and vacation
time does not account for the increasing
number of employers as we just heard
that allow for paid time off but don't
track
usage 378 will increase employer costs
if the employee if if the employee opts
to not take vacation which is the
example that you just
heard so that they can collect that
extra pay check and so if House Bill 378
were to be enacted employers would be
reluctant to design paid time off
policies that offer flexibility to
employees it would constrict the
relationship between the employer and
the employee taking that flexibility
away with respect to the 15
days 15 days is just
asking maybe the next year it's 12 days
uh 12 employees maybe it's 10 employees
and so you you the thresholds like that
are never
good so in closing Mr
chair ask the committee to consider the
impact of
costs on the employer the relationships
between the employees and the
employers the flexibility that both
parties have not unlike some of the
arguments you heard a couple of weeks
ago on the small little Bill House Bill
238 and let's not let the government be
even more invasive into the relationship
between employers and employees so with
that I ask the committee to find house
build 378 an expedient to legislate and
I'd be happy to try and address any
have thank you sir I appreciate your
testimony seeing no questions thank you
very much thank you very
good I'd like to call Alex
cob Kris Kris gotcha sorry my penmanship
isn't great uh thank you Mr chair and
and members of the committee my name is
Alex kbis I'm here to represent the
associated general contractors of New
Hampshire where the state's leading
commercial construction industry organ
organization representing companies in
the highway and building divisions of
the industry thank you for hosting the
annual public hearing on this bill I
think it's I know year six or seven I've
lost count but we have been and continue
to oppose this
legislation uh a lot of what I have
written down was already mentioned but
I'll I'll be very very brief Mr chairman
many companies including contractors are
shifting away from separate buckets of
vacation sick and holiday time
instead time off is available whenever
the employee wants to use it an employee
may never get sick but have a sick child
sick relative they may want to take
personal time for other reasons they
don't want to take vacation so as a
result companies have responded by
offering more flexible options this bill
despite what the sponsor said and I do
appreciate his Amendment which which is
an quite a decent improvement from the
bill is introduced but it still has a
lot of problems it does put everyone in
the same box and I believe that the bill
if you pass it this year you're going to
be right back here in 2026 trying to fix
all the problems with implementation
because it literally is going to affect
thousands of employees in the state some
of the issues include partial layoffs
what happens if an employees hours are
reduced and therefore their time off
would be reduced how would that be
handled how are seasonal employees
handled under this bill we we agree with
the Department of Labor the term
reasonable Assurance doesn't work in the
Contracting World employees must use
their vacation time before applying for
unemployment paving companies for
example will lay off employees in the
cold winter months and there's no
assurance that they're going to come
back they might come back but they might
not come back uh some some employers I
talked to some pavers this morning some
of them offer time off to the seasonal
staff some do not so how is that going
to be handled under this bill uh again
some employees the company I worked at I
came to AGC on July 8th but the company
I worked at before that I had unlimited
time off we didn't they didn't track it
I as long as I got my work done I could
take off as much time as I wanted to so
how are those situations going to be
handled under this bill I agree with
with Mr berky this would require anyone
who has a use it or lose it policy to to
strike that from their handbook and
rewrite it and adapt to what this
legislation is
proposing so the bottom line here is if
you pass this bill I believe that your
constituents most of them are going to
end up with less vacation time employees
are just going to respond to limit their
exposure and to create less generous
vacation packages that's going to be the
result of this Bill yes a few people who
uh are laid off or their company is sold
in those very narrow
circumstances they may get some of that
time off paid but the the the vast
majority of people are going to have
less vacation time if this bill is
passed in our opinion so with that I
would again urge you to kill this bill
once again and allow the employer to
continue to to be flexible and Nimble
and give their employees the flexibility
that they want thank you Mr chairman all
right thank you for that testimony are
there any
questions oh representative avalani sure
is that a you no it's an easy one um
given that
you
the you represent a lot of seasonal
businesses um a lot of them do for
Paving and Contracting they do take the
winters off but then come back in the
summer um would your long-term employees
that do come back would they be forced
to take all of their pay or be paid out
for all of their acred time prior to
coming back with the with the way this
structured again I think it depends on
that term reasonable assurance and how
how the do is going to interpret and
enforce that provision so I think it's
it's a question that we have under this
bill I think you rais a good point and I
I don't think the way it's constructed
now in the legislation I think it
creates confusion and we need to clarify
it hopefully you won't pass the bill but
if you were I think it need would need
to be further defined thank you thank
you Mr
chairman all right any further
questions all right seeing no further
questions thank you for your testimony
you're
please uh Miss chair and members thank
you again for the opportunity to testify
my name is John Reynolds I'm the state
director for the national Federation of
Independent Business in New Hampshire we
represent over 1,700 small businesses
across the state in every
sector a lot of what I wanted to say has
already been said uh much better than I
could say it so um I do want to say I
appreciate representative K Hill's
willingness to have conversations about
the bill and explain where he's coming
from and uh agree that the amendment
moves it a little bit in the right
direction uh but ultimately we continue
to oppose the bill because as Mr berky
uh aptly pointed out it removes
flexibility for employers and employees
and when an employer has a policy that
says that they are not going to be paid
out that that vacation's not going to be
paid out but maybe it's rolled over from
year to year or they're uh giving you a
little bit extra vacation
right an employee is not being denied
value when it's not paid out that value
is being put back in somewhere else in
the compensation package most likely or
put up put back into the business
somewhere else and ultimately small
employers have to live within their
means this bill doesn't make their
compensation budget bigger it just
divides tells the it it takes a chunk of
the compensation budget and tells the
employer how they have to use it which
removes flexibility to offer more
vacation time or offer more carryover or
offer some other benefit that their
employees want and that's what small
employers want to do they want to create
compensation packages that that help
help keep and attract employees
um so with that I'll just leave it there
and uh and have to answer any questions
thank you I appreciate your testimony
questions from the committee saying none
thank you sir appreciate
it seeing no further questions and no
further
P Mr ber do you have a copy of testimony
sir
okay thank you appreciate it um so this
378 um before we break a couple a couple
things first of all great job today good
good questions uh and I really enjoyed I
learned a lot uh so thank you for that
um next week we'll meet at 10: uh up in
our standard room
um in this schedule based on the amount
of tears and whining and those types of
things we will have an hour lunch
tomorrow as long as we can restrain or
next week we'll have a hour lunch as
long as we can restrain our questions to
meet the timeline but no I 30 minutes is
way too short and uh I appreciate your
Indulgence but next week we'll go to an
hour any questions comments
concerns great good work thank you so
what's
that
almost if you are responsible for a
blurb noon tomorrow please or sooner to
me